VERY LIKE TO CALL --
TO ORDER.
THE THIS MEETING OF THE SELECT
COMMITTEE ON NATURAL DISASTER
RESPONSE RECOVERY IN REBUILDING.
THIS IS A TOUGH THE TOPIC FOR
THIS MORNING IS A VERIZON
WIRELESS'S DATA THROTTLING HAVE
THE MEDICINE A COMPLEX
FIREFIGHTERS INTERNET ACCESS.
THAT OCCURRED THIS YEAR.
I WANT TO SAY THANK YOU AND
WELCOME TO EVERYONE WHO IS HERE
WITH US.
AND I WANNA SAY THANK YOU
ESPECIALLY TO MY CO CHAIR MISLI
MOAN AND TO THE OTHER MEMBERS
WHO HAVE MADE TIME TO BE WITH US
THIS MORNING TO TALK ABOUT THIS
TOPIC.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THOSE WHO
HAVE AGREED TO GIVE TESTIMONY
TODAY.
LIKE MOST OF YOU I WAS TAKEN
ABACK AND FRANKLY THAT'S PUTTING
IT MILDLY. TO LEARN THAT A
CELLULAR SALES REP COULD HINDER
THE EFFORTS OF FIREFIGHTERS WHO
WERE RESPONDING TO WHAT HAS
TURNED INTO.
CALIFORNIA'S LARGEST WILDFIRE IN
STATE HISTORY.
BUT I WANT TO BE CLEAR EVEN
THOUGH WE ARE RIGHT TO BE
INDIGNANT.
AND EVEN THOUGH WE ARE RIGHT TO
BE OUTRAGED WE'RE HERE TODAY TO
DO SOMETHING MORE PRODUCTIVE
THAN SIMPLY VENTING OUR ANGER.
WE ARE LOOKING FOR ANSWERS WE
ARE SEARCHING FOR ANSWERS.
WE WANT A DEEPER UNDERSTANDING
WE WANT TO KNOW.
HOW CAN WE GUARANTEE THAT THE
WOMEN AND THE MEN WHO PUT THEIR
LIVES ON THE LINE FOR US?
HAVE THE TOOLS THEY NEED TO
PROTECT US.
BECAUSE LIKE EVERYONE EVERYTHING
ELSE IN OUR LIVES FIRE FIGHTING
AND EMERGENCY RESPONSE ARE
DEPENDENT ON COMMUNICATION
SPECIFICALLY IN THIS CASE MOBILE
DATA.
IT HAS BECOME.
A CRITICAL TOOL.
AND IN THE SAME WAY WE WOULD
NEVER ACCEPT A WATER DEPARTMENT.
SHUTTING OFF HYDRANTS TO GET A
BETTER PER GALLON PRICE FOR
WATER WE WILL NEVER ACCEPT THAT
PUBLIC SAFETY IS LEFT WITHOUT
THE TOOLS THEY NEED SIMPLY
BECAUSE THE COMPANY HAS A
PRICING PLAN.
THEY WANT TO MAXIMIZE.
SO AGAIN WE AREN'T HERE MERELY
TO CASTIGATE ONE PARTICULAR
COMPANY.
WE'RE HERE TO FIND OUT WHAT
HAPPENED AND EVEN MORE
IMPORTANTLY WHAT WE CAN DO TO
ENSURE THAT THIS NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN.
LIKE TURN THIS OVER TO MY
CULTURE MISS THE MARK
[inaudible]
THINK YOU [inaudible]
ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
THANK YOU SO A MEMBER AT LEVINE
AND ALSO TO OUR COLLEAGUES IN
THE RIVER WALDRON ASSOCIATE
AGUILAR CURRY AND ASSEMBLY
MEMBER.
RODRIGUEZ FOR JOINING US TODAY
AYE AYE AYE AYE WANTS YOU TO
START OFF BY.
NOT JUST THINKING EVERYONE
THAT'S HERE BUT ALSO BY A I AM
OUTLINING MY GOAL OF THIS
PARTICULAR --
HEARING AND THAT IS ONE THAT
PROVIDES INFORMATION FOR S. --
OVER THE LAST.
WEEK OVER THE LAST DAYS WE HAD A
NUMBER OF QUESTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN RAISED ABOUT THE PROCESS
ABOUT WHAT MAY OR MAY NOT HAVE
HAPPENED.
AND IT YOU KNOW IT ON THIS FIRE
THAT WE EXPERIENCED IN THE
DISTRICT AND KNOWING HOW.
AND WHEN YOU ARE IN A COMMUNITY
THAT'S GOING THROUGH.
AND EMERGENCY OF THIS SCALE.
ON THAT WE HAD WITH THE THOMAS
FIRE HERE ARE NUMBER OF
QUESTIONS THAT COME UP ABOUT A
NUMBER OF ISSUES YOU REALIZE
THAT IMPERFECTIONS AND AND
INCONSISTENCIES EXIST.
I'M IN ALL AREAS AND THE BEST
THING WE CAN DO IS TRY TO
UNDERSTAND I'M WHAT MAY OR MAY
NOT THAT CURRENTLY BE HAPPENING
HAVE HAPPENED AND COULD
POTENTIALLY HAPPEN IN THE FUTURE.
AND SO THE GOAL FOR ME FOR THIS
PARTICULAR HEARING IS TO REALLY
TRY TO GET THERE TO UNDERSTAND
THE PAST THE PRESENT AND THE
FUTURE.
ABOUT THIS PARTICULAR ISSUE
RELATED.
I HAD TO THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
OF FIRE CHIEFS AND VERIZON I
THINK THAT IT'S IMPORTANT FOR US
TO HAVE A CONVERSATION I HAVE
QUESTIONS FOR ALL OF YOU.
ON AND I'M GLAD WE'RE HERE AND
ME TOGETHER IN IN THE SPIRIT OF
TRYING TO IDENTIFY AND THE PAST
PRESENT AND FUTURE AND HOW WE
INSURE.
THAT -- ALL
PUBLIC SAFETY AYE HAS THE TOOLS
THEY NEED ON IN SOME OF OUR
HARDEST MOMENTS --
IN CALIFORNIA'S HISTORIES
BATTLING THESE NATURAL DISASTERS
I WISH THAT THESE WERE ISOLATED
NATURAL DISASTERS THAT WERE
GOING TO EXIST BUT ON WHAT WE
SAW LAST YEAR AND WHAT WE
CONTINUE TO SEE IN.
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IS THAT THESE
ARE BECOMING A AT THAT THAN THE
NORM I'M IN OUR STATE AND AS
THINGS BECAUSE NORMS WE ALSO
CHANGE HOW WE THINK.
ABOUT POLICIES THAT TO AND MAY
HAVE APPLIED IN A RANDOM
SITUATION AND NOW I HAVING TO BE
APPLIED ON A MORE CONSISTENT
BASIS.
SO THANK YOU ALL AND I THINK
WE'RE GOING TO AT WELCOME ALL
AGAIN AT OUR COLLEAGUES AND SEE
IF ANYBODY HAS SOME BRIEF WORDS
AT TO SAY AS WE START THIS
HEARING [inaudible]
MISS WALDRON.
THANK YOU JUST REALLY BRIEFLY --
YOU KNOW THE THE ISSUE BEFORE US
DEMONSTRATES THE CRITICAL NEED
TO ENHANCE PUBLIC SAFETY INTER
AGENCY COMMUNICATION STATE WIDE.
WHICH YOU KNOW WILL HELP TO SAVE
LIVES IT'S SOMETHING WE'VE BEEN
WORKING ON FOR A LONG TIME --
IN EVEN GOING BACK TO MY DAYS IN
THE CITY COUNCIL AND WE DID THE
EIGHT HUNDRED MEGAHERTZ SYSTEM.
BECAUSE OF BLACKOUT AREAS AND
THINGS LIKE THAT JUST BETWEEN
OUR OWN CITY OF PUBLIC SAFETY --
THE ISSUES YOU KNOW WE'VE FACED
MOST OF US ON THIS COMMITTEE.
HAVE HAD DISASTERS RECENTLY AND
IN THE PAST IN OUR DISTRICTS.
AND YOU KNOW. FOR ME HAVING THE
CEDAR FIRE THE WHICH THE WAY
HE'D OQOQO SLY LACK IT GOES ON
AND ON EVERY TIME WE LEARN MORE.
AND THAT COMMUNICATION IS A
CRITICAL ISSUE PUBLIC SAFETY
OBVIOUSLY YOU KNOW PREVENTION
CRITICAL ISSUE SO THE ADMISSION
OF THIS COMMITTEE IS TO ACTUALLY.
COALESCE THE EXPERIENCES WE'VE
ALL HAD TO BUILD ON THE SO THAT
WE DON'T HAVE TO REPEAT THINGS
FROM THE PAST SO WE CAN MOVE
FORWARD SO.
I LOOK FORWARD TO THE DISCUSSION.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON IS I'VE
WORKED VERY.
WELL MAKE IT QUICK --
SAFETY SAFETY SAFETY.
THAT'S WHAT THIS IS ABOUT FOR ME --
YOU KNOW MY OF MY DISTRICT HAS
BEEN ON FIRE FOR THREE YEARS.
AND TO FIND OUT SOMETHING LIKE
THIS MAY HAVE HAPPENED IN MY
HERE TO POINT FINGERS BUT I
DON'T WANT IT HAPPENED AGAIN.
ONE SURE THAT WE HAVE --
TAKING CARE OF OUR PUBLIC SAFETY --
INDIVIDUALS TO MAKE SURE THAT
THEY'RE SAFE.
AND IN REALLY WORRIES ME THAT
THEY MAY HAVE BEEN IN HARM'S WAY
BY NOT HAVING THE ACCESS.
TO A COMMUNICATIONS SO WITH THAT
I'M IN TODAY AND A THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR PUTTING THIS
TOGETHER SOME REMEMBER
[inaudible]
THANK YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
YES FOR SMALLER THANK BOTH
CHAIRS LIMONIUM --
LEVINE FOR BRINGING US TOGETHER
AND VERY IMPORTANT HEARING --
I THINK YOU ALL KNOW AS MY PEERS
BACKGROUND IT AS A FIRST
RESPONDER FOR OVER THIRTY YEARS.
COMMUNICATION IS KEY TO DOING
OUR JOB AS FIRST RESPONDERS WARY
OF THE FAR FAR THE POLICE
OFFICER ANYBODY ELSE.
WHEN YOU'RE OUT THERE DOING YOUR
JOB TO PROTECT PEOPLE IN AND
SAVE LIVES --
I'M LOOKING FOR TO DISCUSSION WE
HAVE TODAY I WAS PRETTY MUCH
BOTHERED BY THE INSTANCE WE
HEARD THAT OCCURRED IN THAT FIRE
IN. ONE THING I HATE TO SEE TIME
AND TIME AGAIN THAT.
THEY HAVE TO TAKE SOME TYPE OF A
MERGER DISASTER OR SEE THERE'S
FAILURE STRIKE THE SOMETHING'S
NOT WORKING RIGHT.
PASADENA CALIFORNIA WERE A STATE
THAT'S PRONE TO DISASTERS WHERE
THE FIRES THE FLOODS.
AND WE HAVE THAT BIG EARTHQUAKE
GLOOMY THAT IT CAN OCCUR ANY DAY
ANY TIME.
SO WE REALLY NEED TO BE SURE
THAT WE'RE WORKING TOGETHER WITH
EVERYBODY TO MAKE SURE THAT.
WERE ALREADY WE ARE PREPARED
MORE THAN EVER TO RESPOND ANY
TYPE OF DISASTER THAT THERE
AREN'T ANY --
ANY ISSUES THAT CAN HAPPEN
HAMPER OUR FIRST RESPONDERS TO
DOING THEIR JOB.
SO WITHOUT --
VERY EAGER TO HEAR OF WHAT
OCCURRED WHAT WE HAVE MOVING
FORWARD.
AND LET'S MAKE SURE THINGS LIKE
THIS DON'T HAPPEN AGAIN IN THE
STATE'S SPECIAL COMMITTEE FOR
SHIP OWNERS AND THANK YOU ONCE
AGAIN FOR OUR BRING MR ALANIS.
THANK YOU MISTER RODRIGUEZ
MISTER CHIP.
THANK YOU WAS A CO CHAIRS HAD
FOR HOSTING OF MEETING AND ALSO
I WANNA TAKE --
DISCOVERED HIM AND HE TO SANK TO
SEND THE CLARA COUNTY
FIREFIGHTERS TO BRING THIS ISSUE
AND A TO TO OUR ATTENTION.
I DON'T KNOW DISMISSED THE FIRST
TIME THAT HAPPENED.
THAT EVER HAPPENED BEFORE BUT
I'M DEFINITELY HOPING THAT IT
GOOD OUT OF SYNC TALKED AT THIS
IS TO LAST TIME.
THERE WILL HAVE TO SEE A
COMMUNICATION BREAKDOWN SO AFTER
THIS HEARING ON A REALLY LOOK
COMPOSED OVER TO SOME A REAL
SOLUTION THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
THANK YOU MISTER CHIEF AT THIS
TIME I WOULD LIKE TO WELCOME --
TO THAT TABLE I'D FIRE CHIEF
TONY ABOUT IN.
AND IF YOU'VE GOT STAFF THAT
WANT TO JOIN YOU PLEASE.
WE'VE GOT OPERATIONS CHIEF SIDE
GLASS HERE WITH US AS WELL.
AND COUNTY COUNCIL AYE DANIEL
GOLDSTEIN [inaudible]
OUR GREAT.
SO PERSONAL CHIEF THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR BEING HERE AND THANK
YOU FOR YOUR SERVICE.
THIS HAS BEEN THE WORST FIRE
SEASON --
EVER IF FOR THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND THE WOMEN AND MEN
OF YOUR PROFESSION HAVE DONE AN
UNBELIEVABLE JOB.
AND YOU HAVE THE ADMIRATION AND
GRATITUDE OF OUR STATE I'D LIKE
TO WELCOME YOU NOW FOR YOUR
OPENING STATEMENT.
GREAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH WHOM.
CHAIRMAN LEVINE MADAM CHAIR
ALONE.
ASSEMBLY NUMBERS.
IT'S COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US HERE TODAY AND I
HEARING US I HAVE THE EXPERIENCE
YOU'VE HEARD MY DEPUTY CHIEF OF
OPERATIONS.
CHIEF GLASS.
AND NOW WILL BE HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS YOU HAVE AND I DO
HAVE A BRIEF RECAP IF YOU WISH.
YES PLEASE I UNDERSTAND YOU'VE --
HAVE A A TIMELINE OF OF WHAT HAD
OCCURRED AND IF YOU WELL I THINK
THAT THE COMMITTEE WOULD BE GLAD
TO HEAR IT [inaudible]
VERY GOOD.
SO IS MY ROLE IS THE FIRE CHIEF
IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY ALSO SERVE
AS THE CALLOW YES OPERATIONAL
AREA FIRE COORDINATOR PROFFER
LEGAL AID THAT EITHER LEAVES ARE
COUNTING FOR COMES INTO OUR
COUNTY.
NOW ARE ORGANIZATION IS A VERY
ACTIVE ORGANIZATION MANY THE
FIRES I HEARD MENTION BEFORE WE
CAME UP HERE TODAY.
OUR DEPARTMENT PERSONNEL MORE AT
WE WERE AT THE THOMAS FIRE WHERE
THE FLOODS IN A SANTA BARBARA
THE MUD SLIDES --
WE ARE CURRENTLY AT THE
MENDOCINO COMPLEX FOR SMALLER
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AGENCY.
AND IT IS VERY RARE. TO SEND OUT
THE AMOUNT OF RESOURCES WE DO
BUT WE SHIP [inaudible]
ITS MISSION.
AND WE SUPPORT OUR PERSONNEL AND
WE'RE VERY FORTUNATE TO HAVE A
GOVERNING BOARD THAT SPORTS THAT
AS WELL THE COUNTY BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS.
SENATOR COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT.
EASILY.
WE'RE ACTIVE PARTICIPANT AS I
SAID IN THE MUTUAL AID SYSTEM.
WE RESPOND TO ASSIST OUR
NEIGHBORS WITH INCIDENTS LARGE
AND SMALL.
WE LIKE LIKE NEARLY ALL FIRED
PERMITS A CALIFORNIA WE ASSIST
IN ALL ASPECTS OF THESE
EMERGENCIES FROM ACTIVE
FIREFIGHTER.
INCIDENT MANAGEMENT TO SUPPORT.
OUR RESPONSES TO THESE INCIDENTS
HAVE REVOLVED HAVE THE BALL TO
RELY ON INTERNET BASED SYSTEMS.
TO PROVIDE CRITICAL
COMMUNICATIONS TO OTHER
RESPONDERS AND THE PUBLIC.
RESPONDERS RELY ON MOBILE
WIRELESS CONNECTIVITY TO
COMMUNICATE RESOURCE STATUS
[inaudible]
PLEASE ORDERS.
PROVIDE CRITICAL INCIDENT
INFORMATION.
AND DEVELOP INTO ACTION PLANS
WHICH IS THE PLANNING TOOL WE
USE TO MANAGE THESE LARGE MARKET.
SIX THE PUBLIC RELIES ON OUR
ABILITY TO PROVIDE THEM
INFORMATION ABOUT EVACUATIONS
IT'S THAT MAPS RECOVERY
RESOURCES.
AND OTHER SPECIAL INSTRUCTIONS
THAT ARE FREQUENTLY CRITICAL TO
THEIR SAFETY.
OUR ABILITY TO CONNECT MAINTAIN
INTERNET CONNECTIVITY.
IS CRITICAL TO OUR PUBLIC SAFETY
MISSION UNFORTUNATELY.
OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS WE
EXPERIENCE A SITUATION WHERE OUR
CAR CONNECTIVITY WAS THROTTLED
BY A PROVIDER.
THIS OCCURRED JUST DESPITE
SEVERAL CONVERSATIONS WITH OUR
ACCOUNT REPRESENTATIVE.
THAT THE DEVICES WERE PROVIDING
ESSENTIAL SERVICES.
LAWLER FIRE FIREBALLS
FIREFIGHTERS WERE ABLE TO
IDENTIFY.
A WORKAROUND WHY WE CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH OUR SERVICE PROVIDER.
I FOUND THE SITCH I FOUND THE
SITUATION PERSONALLY TO BE
UNACCEPTABLE.
I BELIEVE THE NEED FOR
CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC SAFETY
AGENCIES.
AND THE PUBLIC WE SERVE. TO HAVE
ACCESS TO A ROBUST WIRELESS
NETWORK DURING LARGE EMERGENCIES
AND DISASTERS IS CRITICAL.
THE PUBLIC SAFETY.
I THINK YOU GET FOR HERE EARLY
THIS MORNING AND HAPPY TO ANSWER
ANY QUESTIONS HAVE.
THANK YOU CHIEF --
YOU YOU TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
THE USE OF DATA [inaudible]
AND THERE'S SOMETHING ABOUT THE
EXPERIENCE THAT YOU WENT THROUGH
THAT.
ALMOST EVERY CONSUMER GOES
THROUGH THEMSELVES THEY HAVE TO
SELECT A DATA PLAN [inaudible]
FOR THEIR PHONE SERVICE
[inaudible]
AND WHAT IS THAT PROCESS LIKE.
FOR A FIRE AGENCY.
AND HOW OFTEN DO YOU DO THAT.
AND HOW HOW IS IT DIFFERENT FROM.
WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT YOUR PERSONALLY I TRYING TO
DO?
IT IS DIFFERENT WE DO YOU HAVE
THE MAJOR ACCOUNTS MANAGER THAT
WE WORK WITH --
THAT ALONE IS SPECIFIC TO
GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTS TO HELP US
DETERMINE WHAT THAT PLAYERS
SHOULD BE THEY ARE LOW BUT
COMPLICATED BASED ON OUR NEEDS
AND OUR SERVICE.
AND YOU KNOW IN THIS CASE --
WE HAD A PREVIOUS INCIDENT.
EARLY DECEMBER WHERE THERE WERE
THROTTLING AND THERE'S IF I
COULD JUST ASK YOU BEFORE YOU
CONTINUETO KEEP CERTAIN OF THE
MICROPHONE A LITTLE CLOSER TO
YOU.
THANK YOU THERE YOU.
SO WHEN WE CHOOSE OUR REPLY WE
WORK WITH OUR MAJOR ACCOUNTS --
MANAGER.
WE DID FIRST EXPERIENCE
THROTTLING ISSUE IN DECEMBER
TWENTY SEVENTEEN AND OUR
ACCOUNTS MANAGER WAS RESPONSIVE
IT WAS --
THAT RESULTED IN IT BEING
ELIMINATED IN ABOUT TWENTY
MINUTES AFTER REQUEST WAS MADE.
AND WE WORKED WITH OUR PROVIDER
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR PLAN I
WOULD NOT BE THROTTLED IN THE
FUTURE.
AS NORMAL ON PUBLIC SAFETY YOU
HAVE TIMES WHEN YOU'RE VERY BUSY
LIKE RIGHT NOW.
WHEN YOU HAVE TIMES WHEN YOU'RE
NOT VERY BUSY --
BETWEEN DECEMBER.
AND THE FIRES THAT BEGAN IN JUNE.
FOUND WE HAD A LITTLE BIT OF
DOWNTIME AND OUR DEVICES WERE
UTILIZED AS HEAVILY [inaudible]
IN JUNE.
OUR SUPPORT UNIT WAS DEPLOYED
AGAIN.
A TWO THE PARTY FIRE AND INTO
THE MENDOCINO COMPLEX.
A WHILE AT THE POINTY IT YEAH.
IT BEGAN TO EXPERIENCE
THROTTLING AGAIN.
WE AGAIN WORK THROUGH OUR
SERVICE PROVIDER WE ARE UNABLE
TO GET A HOLD OF OUR ACCOUNTS
MANAGER AT THAT TIME.
SO LIKE THE GENERAL PUBLIC.
OUR IT OFFICER DO WHATEVER HE
COULD TO WORK THROUGH THE
GENERAL CUSTOMER SERVICE LINE --
WAS ABLE TO GET A HOLD TECH
SUPPORT.
AND LIFT THE THROTTLING ON THAT
UNIT.
ALBEIT VERY TEMPORARILY.
NOW WE DID CHANGE PLANS AT THAT
TIME -- TO A
SLIGHTLY HIGHER ALERT HIGHER
RATE PLAN.
AND THEN THEY WENT TO THE
MENDOCINO COMPLEX.
AT THE MENACING OF COMPLEX THERE
AGAIN EXPERIENCING PROUDLY.
IT WAS AT THIS TIME THAT WE
CONTINUE TO CONTACT OUR OWN
ACCOUNTS MANAGER.
AND HAVE SENTINEL DOUBLE EMAILS.
LEFT PHONE MESSAGES WERE ABLE TO
GET A HOLD OF OUR ACCOUNTS
MANAGER IN A TIMELY MANNER.
DURING THIS TIME OUR IT STAFF
WORKED VERY DILIGENTLY TO
DEVELOP WORKAROUNDS.
THEY LIT UP THE HOT SPOT ON ONE
OF THE ADJACENT UNITS PHONE FOR
THEM TO USE.
HOW WE OVERNIGHT SHIFT ANOTHER
PROVIDERS?
CARD AND ROUTING DEVICE.
AND WE WERE ABLE TO GET THAT UP
AND RUNNING BY THE NEXT DAY.
BEFORE THE SITUATION WAS
RESOLVED.
THEY'RE CONTINUING TO UTILIZE
THAT REDUNDANT A DEVICE --
AT THIS POINT AND THEY STILL
REMAIN ATENCIO COMPLEX.
YOU IN IN SOME OF THE ACCOUNTS
DISCUSS HOW INFORMATION IS
COMMUNICATED THROUGH AND OH YES
FIVE SIXTY TWO DEVICE CAN YOU
TELL US A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT.
SURE I'D ACTUALLY LIKE TO HAVE
MY DEPUTY CHIEF OF OPERATIONS
JUST PROVIDE YOU A BRIEF
OVERVIEW OF WHAT THAT UNIT IS.
ON IT IS A SUPPORT UNIT --
THAT A WE STAFF AS A SIGN THE
FOR CALIFORNIA STATE OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICES FIFTH GLASS.
SO GOOD MORNING.
MY NAME IS BRYAN GLASS
OPERATIONS CHIEF FOR SENATOR
COUNTY FIRE DEPARTMENT --
ó YES FIFTY TO SIXTY TUESDAY
INCIDENTS SUPPORT VEHICLE THAT --
WE PARTNER WITH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES TO SEND OUT UPON THEIR
REQUEST TO COORDINATE THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT MUTUAL AID OF
RESOURCES --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA CALIFORNIA'S ONE OF
THE LARGEST --
STATES AND MOVES THE MOST AMOUNT
OF RESOURCES DURING A GIVEN TIME --
SO WE'LL MOVE RESOURCES FROM
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA TO NORTHERN
CALIFORNIA NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND ALL
OF THAT IS COORDINATED THROUGH
THESE INCIDENTS SUPPORT VEHICLES.
THERE SEVEN OF THEM LOCATED
THROUGHOUT --
CALIFORNIA BASED ON THAT WE ASK
YOU -- TO
BREAKDOWN AND SANTA CLARA COUNTY
FIRE DEPARTMENT PROVIDES THE
STAFFING ON THOSE UNITS SO IS
RESOURCES ARE COMING IN FROM ALL
THE DIFFERENT JURISDICTIONS ARE
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA --
FEDERAL RESOURCES ARE
COORDINATED THEIR DOD FISH AND
WILDLIFE BUREAU OF INDIAN
AFFAIRS --
UNITED STATES FOREST SERVICE ALL
THOSE RESOURCES ARE PASSING
THROUGH THE YES FIFTY TO SIXTY
TWO VEHICLE FOR ACCOUNTABILITY.
RESOURCE TRACKING --
ASSIGNMENT REASSIGNMENT AS WELL
AS ALL THE FINANCIAL --
PAPERWORK THAT IS BEING TRACKED --
THROUGH THE OFFICE OF EMERGENCY
SERVICES MUTUAL AID --
THE VEHICLE USES A HIGH AMOUNT
OF DATA BECAUSE IT IT'S TRACKING
IN NEAR REAL TIME THE MOVEMENT
OF THE SOVIET GOALS --
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AND AS URGENCY IS
BREAK IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
THOSE RESOURCES MAY NEED TO BE
REDIRECTED TO IN NEW AND
EMERGING THREATS WITHIN THE
STATE -- SO
THIS VEHICLE --
IS IS A HUB OF ACTIVITY ON ANY
CONNECTS WITH THE OPERATIONS
CENTER HERE INSIDE --
SAN SACRAMENTO --
SO THAT ARE THOSE RESOURCES ARE
NEEDED MOST --
AND WE HAD THE PLEASURE OF
STAFFING THAT WITH THEM IT'S A
JOINT PARTNERSHIP --
AND THAT IS --
KIND OF A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF SOME
OF THE DATA USES THAT THERE THAT
ARE REQUIRED ARE LIKE I SAID
APPARATUS ROUTING TRACKING
MAPPING --
INCIDENT MAPS INCIDENT ACTION
PLAN DISSEMINATION AS WELL AS
WE'VE HAD A REALLY GOOD --
PARTNERSHIP WITH THEIR NATIONAL
GUARD IN THE UNMANNED AERIAL.
VEHICLES AND THE LIVE FEED OF
VIDEO DATA THAT IS FLOWN DURING
THE EVENING HOURS AND THEN PUSH
DOWN SO WE CAN HAVE ACTUALLY
LIVE.
FOOTAGE FLOWING INTO THAT
VEHICLE SO THAT --
OPERATIONAL COMMANDERS ON THE
GROUND CAN MAKE DECISIONS AND IN
NEAR REAL TIME ABOUT WHERE THEY
NEED TO DEPLOY ASSETS THAT ARE
ON THE FIRE --
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS A LOT OF THE
ISSUE AROUND OUR OUR DATA NEED
IS LIVE STREAMING VIDEO.
THANK YOU FOR DESCRIBING THAT IN
A DIFFERENT RANGE OF OF DATA
THAT YOU'RE YOU'RE USING BECAUSE
THESE ARE THINGS THAT MOST
PEOPLE ARE TALKING ABOUT AND
ALSO THESE.
SOUND LIKE HIGH DATA USE FILES
YES AS WELL WHAT IT AND THIS IS
A DEVICE THAT KNOWN MOST PEOPLE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT AS WELL.
WATER THAT WAS THE RANGE OF
DEVICES THAT YOU'RE UTILIZING
HOW DO YOU MANAGE ALL OF THOSE
DEVICES AND THEN HOW DO YOU ALSO
MAY.
ALL OF THE PLANS THAT EACH
DEVICE MUST BE ON YOU ARE TALK.
* ABOUT THE CONTRACTS SURE --
SO RIGHT NOW WE HAVE --
FOR OUR DEPARTMENT WERE NOT ONLY
LARGE TO PAY FOR IT OR ABOUT
FIFTEEN STATION THAT'S A WERE
MEDIUM SIZE ORGANIZATION.
AND WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT DEVICES
THAT ARE KIND CONNECTED YOU'RE
STILL LOOKING AT I THINK
SOMEWHERE IN THE RANGE OF OVER
THREE HUNDRED DEVICES --
AND THAT INCLUDES HOT SPOTS ON
IPADS PHONE CELLULAR PHONES --
ROUTERS EVERY SINGLE ONE OF OUR
APPARATUS HAS A CREEL POINT THE
VICE WHICH HOLDS THE SIM CARDS.
AND CREEKS THAT WIFI HOTSPOT
OVER OUR VEHICLES --
WHAT A LOT OF PEOPLE DON'T
REALIZE IS SOMETHING SIMPLE AS A
PATIENT CARE REPORT DURING AN
EMERGENCY MEDICAL CALL?
BACK IT'S UPLOADED THROUGH THAT
SYSTEM AND SENT TO THE HOSPITAL
AUTOMATICALLY OVER WIRELESS.
ON THERE'S A LOT OF USES FOR
WIRELESS IN THE FIRE SERVICE WE
HAVE QUITE A FEW DEVICES THAT
ARE ALL CONNECTED WE DO HAVE AN
INTERNAL IT STAFF THAT MANAGES
THAT WORKS DIRECTLY WITH OUR
ACCOUNT.
REPRESENTATIVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE MANAGE THAT PLAN
APPROPRIATELY.
SO FOR ALL THESE DEVICES THEY
COULD BE SITTING IDLE.
NOT USING DATA.
AND TELL THE EVENTS THAT OCCUR
IS THAT YOU NEED THAT DATA --
YOU HOW HOW DO YOU.
JACKSON OR PLANNED.
FOR WHAT SERVICE WOULD BE
REQUIRED IN A CIRCUMSTANCE LIKE
THAT IS EFFICIENT IS OUR
DIFFERENT WAY TO DO IT THAT
MIGHT BE MORE RESPONSIVE.
TO YOUR AGENCIES NEEDS AND THE
REAL USE OF THIS EQUIPMENT.
BUT THAT THAT'S A REALLY GREAT
QUESTION THANK YOU FOR THAT THE
ON THE THING ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY
IS IT IS.
VERY DIFFICULT AS HARD AS WE TRY
AND WE ANALYZE THE DATA TO
PREDICT WHEN EVENTS ARE GONNA
HAPPEN.
WHETHER BE A SMALL DENT WHERE
THERE BE A LARGE EVENT.
SO THERE ARE TIMES THAT YOU HAVE
DOWNTIME THERE ARE TIMES THAT
AND YOU HAVE A HUGE SPIKES IN
YOUR NEEDS WHEN IT COMES TO DATA.
BUT WE HAVE A SET OF PLANS ARE
REALLY BASED --
FOR AGENCIES OR CONSUMERS.
THAT CAN PLAN OUT.
THEIR DATA NEED BASED ON
HISTORICAL USAGE MONTH BY MONTH.
THAT'S NOT THE CASE WITH PUBLIC
SAFETY.
SO YOU HAVE TO FIND A BALANCE
YOU HAVE TO WORK WITH YOUR
ACCOUNT MATTER WHEN WE ARE A
MEDIUM SIZED PERMIT WE DO NOT
HAVE UNLIMITED FUNDS.
AND WE HAVE TO MAKE SURE THAT
WHEN WE SELECT THE PLAN IT MEETS
OUR NEEDS.
BUT IT ALSO IS NOT A PLAN THAT
IS SO EXPENSIVE IT COMES AT A
COST OF STAFFING.
AND WE'RE ALL CONSTANTLY TRYING
TO FIND THAT BALANCE.
WHEN WORKING WITH THESE PLANTS
THAT REALLY ARE BASED TOWARDS
CONSUMERS?
VERSES THE ALONG.
THE SPECIFIC NEEDS OF PUBLIC
SAFETY.
YOU MAKE A REALLY GOOD POINT
ABOUT DOWN SEEN.
THESE PLANS WITH.
THE COST OF ANOTHER FIREFIGHTER.
HE'S ABLE TO PROTECT THE
COMMUNITY AS WELL AND THE
BUDGETARY.
PRESSURES THAT THAT YOU'RE UNDER.
DO YOU HAVE MORE THAN ONE
SERVICE PROVIDER.
AND WHAT WHAT DOES THAT THE
SECTOR LOOK LIKE FROM A FIRINGS
AGENCY PERSPECTIVE AS TO WHO IS --
SELLING PRODUCTS THAT.
YOUR SECTOR IS THEN LOOKING AT
AND AND THINKING THIS MEETS OUR
NEEDS ARE THERE ONLY A COUPLE
THAT YOU HAVE TO CHOOSE FROM.
AND WHAT IS THAT SELECTION
PROCESS LIKE.
SO FOR OUR AGENCY WERE WERE
LITTLE UNIQUE WE SERVE SEVEN
DIFFERENT CITIES --
INCLUDE A LARGE PORTION OF SANTA
CRUZ MOUNTAIN RANGE AND SO FOR
US IT'S COVERAGE WE'RE LOOKING
WE'RE LOOKING AT COVERAGE WE DO
HAVE MORE THAN ONE SERVICE
PROVIDER.
ON THE WE ARE LOOKING AT WAYS TO
ALWAYS INCREASE REDUNDANCY.
ARM OF ONE PROVIDERS COVERAGE IS
BETTER THAN THE OTHER --
I'M SORRY CAN YOU REPEAT THE
SECOND PART OF THE QUESTION SO I
MEAN IF YOU COULD PLEASE TELL US
YOUR SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE AND
HOW YOU TALK ABOUT COVERAGE
BEING THE MOST IMPORTANT THING.
WE ARE THERE OTHER AREAS WHERE
THE COVERAGE IS BETTER FOR A
DIFFERENT PROVIDER AND SO YOU'RE
YOU KNOW SISTER AGENCIES OF
COURSE ARE GOING FOR THEM
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO DO WITH THE
MOUNTAINOUS.
AREAS THAT YOU'VE GOT BUT MAYBE
HAVE FLATTER AREA WHERE
DIFFERENT PROVIDER WORKS THAT
WOULD LOVE TO KNOW WHO YOUR
OTHER PROVIDERS BESIDES VERIZON
SURE I CAN SPEAK FOR OUR AGENCY
WHICH IS A RIGHT NOW VERIZON IN.
EIGHTEEN EIGHTY I'M SORRY CHIEF
CAGES REPEAT THAT ONE MORE TIME
I PEAK FOR OUR AGENCY ARE NOT
THE OTHERS BUT FAR AGENCIES
VERIZON IN A TNT.
GREAT THANK YOU MISLI NOT.
THANK YOU ANDA.
YEAH THERE'S A HERE AS YOU
DESCRIBE SITUATIONS I ALSO HEARD
YOU REFLECT ON THE FACT THAT YOU
ARE PART OF THE A REALLY A
STATEWIDE EFFORT YOU'VE BEEN IT
NOT JUST IN SANTA CLARA COUNTY
YOU'VE BEEN IN MULTIPLE COUNTIES
SINCE I WON I THINK MORE.
OF A BROAD LEAF FROM.
THE PERSPECTIVE OF THE STATE AND
THIS WAS A A SITUATION THAT
SOUNDS LIKE IT'S HAPPENED TWICE
ONE DECEMBER TWENTY SEVENTEEN
FOR TWENTY MINUTES AND ONE
SOUNDS LIKE A DAY.
SOMETHING LIKE THAT A DAY --
MORE RECENTLY I THINK THAT
THAT'S WHAT I HEARD AND IS THIS
SOMETHING THAT YOU SEE AS A
PATTERN IN SOME OF THE OTHER
FIRES THAT YOU'VE BEEN IN.
IS THIS REALLY KIND OF NARROWED
DOWN TO THESE TWO INSTANCES AND
I'M JUST WONDERING IF YOU CAN
SPEAK ON THAT SINCE --
YOU'VE BEEN PART OF OF HIM.
MULTIPLE FIRES IN MULTIPLE
COUNTIES AND CITIES IN OUR STATE
I'M ALSO RECOGNIZING AND THAT
THE REGIONS ARE DIFFERENT --
A FIRE IN THE HEART OF SANTA
BARBARA MIGHT BE A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT THAN --
ONE IN A RURAL I'M AREA IN
CALIFORNIA. FOR ARE AGENCY WE
WE'VE HAD THREE AND STE
INSTANCES ALONE WITH THE
SPECIFIC UNIT --
OF OF IDENTIFIED. FOR THE AT
OTHER AGENCIES --
I I CAN'T SPEAK TO WHETHER THEY
HAVE BEEN THROTTLED OR NOT --
I CAN TELL YOU THAT --
WHEN YOU'RE ON THESE EVENTS AND
I'VE AS YOU MENTIONED
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLYMEMBER.
THEY CAN BE --
IN MODOC.
WHERE THEY CAN BE OF SANTA CLARA
COUNTY AND AND YOUR COVERAGE
WILL VARY --
IT IS NOT UNCOMMON. FOR
FIREFIGHTERS AT BASE CAMP TO
SWITCH BETWEEN EACH OTHER'S
PHONES SO THAT THEY CAN CONTACT
FAMILY BASED ON COVERAGE BASED
ON OF THEIR ABILITY TO ACCESS
DATA.
ON WE HAVE TO REMEMBER.
THAT ON THE PUBLIC SAFETY SIDE
IT IS.
AND CRITICAL THAT WE HAVE ACCESS
BUT WE'RE ALSO SUPPORTING ARE
PEOPLE OUT THERE THAT ARE ARE
GONE. FOR TWO WEEKS FROM THEIR
FAMILIES AND THEIR ABILITY TO BE
ABLE.
TO CONTACT HER FAMILY AS
CRITICAL AS WELL SO I CAN SPEAK
ON THEIR PERSONAL EXPERIENCES
BECAUSE I PERSONALLY LED THE
STRIKE TEAMS --
BUT AS FAR AS OTHER AGENCIES
[inaudible]
PHONE.
EXPERIENCE THROTTLING I CAN'T
SPEAK TO THAT.
AND MADAM CHAIR WAS --
THOMAS FIRE IN DECEMBER OF
TWENTY SEVENTEEN THE PAWNEE FIRE
IN JUNE OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN AND
THE MENDOCINO COMPLEX IN JULY
[inaudible] TWENTY EIGHTEEN I
THINK YOU AND I LESS THAN TWENTY
FOUR HOURS AGO.
THAT WE SAW THAT --
THE PROVIDER THAT WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT SIDE.
MADE SOME RECOMMENDATIONS TO
THEIR PROGRAM OVERALL THAT WOULD
TRY -- TO
ENSURE THIS DOES NOT HAPPEN
AGAIN FROM YOUR PRINT WHAT ARE
YOUR THOUGHTS AND REACTIONS --
IN ENTER AND I AM AND I DON'T
KNOW IF YOU HAD A CHANCE TO TO
SEE -- BAIL
WHAT THEY WILL BE DOING MOVING
FORWARD I WANT TO SPEAK FOR THEM
BUT I'M JUST CURIOUS --
IN IN TERMS OF YOUR THOUGHTS AND
REACTIONS I TO THEIR PROPOSED
PLAN MOVING FORWARD.
SO I HAVE NOT SEEN THEIR
PROPOSED PLAN --
BUT I WILL SAY THIS PERSONALLY
OWNED.
WITH MY STAFF THEY KNOW I'D
RATHER KEEP MY HEAD DOWN WORK
HARD DIDN'T SPEAK PUBLICLY.
HOUSE SPEAKER TO MY WIFE LAST
NIGHT.
AND SHE SAID IF THIS MAKES A
DIFFERENCE FOR THE FIRE SERVICE
MOVING FORWARD.
YOU NEED TO BE IN THERE BE
STRONG.
AND PUSH FOR CHANGE SO THAT THIS
DOES NOT HAPPEN TO ANY OTHER
FIRE SERVICE PROVIDER.
AND THAT RESONATED WITH ME.
I'VE REALLY TRULY HOPE THAT WHAT
COMES OUT OF THIS IS THAT A
GREATER PARTNERSHIP IN MOVING
FORWARD THAT THIS DOES NOT
HAPPEN AGAIN TO ANY OTHER PUBLIC
HE'S.
AND I APPRECIATE THOSE COMMENTS
I THINK USED UP THE WORD
PARTNERSHIP --
I THINK HAD TO GUESS MY GUESS IS
THAT ALL OF THOSE AND THAT ARE
SITTING ON THIS DIETS WOULD WANT
THE SAME THING THAT THIS IS IT
I'M SOMETHING THAT DOES NOT
HAPPEN.
I'M AGAIN I KNOW THAT EVERY
MINUTES I HAVING LIVED.
THE THOMAS WILDFIRE EVERY SECOND
AND MINUTE MEANT SOMETHING TO US --
AND I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT THAT IS
I COMING HERE AND SHARING THAT
WITH US AND MY FINAL QUESTION IS.
THINKING NOW NOT JUST RELATED TO
THIS INCIDENT --
BUT REFLECTING ON THAT WORD
PARTNERSHIP.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER AGENCIES ARE
INDUSTRIES THAT WE SHOULD BE
THINKING ABOUT PARTNERING WITH
TO IDENTIFY.
A BIG PROBLEM A COMMON PROBLEM
AND OUTSIDE OF JUST THE SPACE IS
THERE SOMETHING ELSE THAT YOUR
SCENE AND THAT IS AN ISSUE TO
OUR PUBLIC SAFETY IN A WAY --
THAT SHOULD WE SHOULD THINK
ABOUT NOW --
AND AND AND MAYBE NOT WHEN WE WE
WE SEE A PROBLEM.
I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS
ESPECIALLY WITH OF THE LARGE
AMOUNT OF FIRES WE'VE HAD OVER
THE LAST SEVERAL YEARS.
AND THERE'S OPPORTUNITY EXISTS.
IF YOU HAD A FIRE IN YOUR
JURISDICTION YOU MAY HAVE LOST A
SOUL FLIGHT.
A AND THEY ARE REBUILDING
SULFITES.
I THINK HARDENING OF OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE.
PROTECT THE CELL SITE WHATEVER
THE PROPRIETOR SHOULD BE A
PRIORITY SO ACCESS OWNED.
CAN BE AVAILABLE IS ROBUST --
THERE IS BACKUP SYSTEMS OUR
GENERATOR SYSTEMS TO KEEP THEM
UP AND RUNNING THERE'S  LOT OF
INFRASTRUCTURE HARDENING THAT WE
CAN DO TO SUPPORT THE OVERALL
SYSTEM.
AND NOT JUST FOR PUBLIC SAFETY.
SO REPUBLICAN ACTUALLY GET THE
MESSAGE.
THAT WE ARE TRYING TO PUT OUT TO
THEM TO CRITICAL INFORMATION
THEY NEED TO PROTECT THEMSELVES
AS WELL.
THAT WOULD BE PROBABLY THE ONE
STRONG RECOMMENDATION I WOULD
HAVE AS WE MOVE FORWARD IN.
MAKE SURE WE DON'T MISS THE
OPPORTUNITY.
AS WE REBUILD A LOT OF THE SITES
TO HARDEN THEM.
AND I THINK AS THOSE ARE
POWERFUL COMMENTS RIGHT NOT
MISSING THE OPPORTUNITY TO DO
BETTER -- TO
REBUILD AND DO WHATEVER IS
NEEDED I'M TO ENSURE THAT THE
PARTNERSHIP IS STRONG AND
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT CALIFORNIANS
WANT AND NEED I'M PARTICULARLY
IN EMERGENCY SERVICES.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR COMMENTS. TWO
OTHER MEMBERS HAVE QUESTIONS AT
THIS POINT MISS AMERICA HAVE
JUST SEVERAL BASIC QUESTION I'M
ASKED THE OTHERS AS WELL
[inaudible]
IN RETROSPECT SINCE YOU HAD THE
INITIAL.
THROTTLING IN DECEMBER.
BUT WOULD YOU HAVE DONE
DIFFERENT.
THAT'S A REALLY GOOD QUESTION WE
I DON'T KNOW IF I WOULD HAVE
DONE ANYTHING DIFFERENT GIVEN
THE RESPONSE THAT WE INITIALLY
RECEIVED.
THE RESPONSE WE INITIALLY
RECEIVED RACKET DECEMBER WAS
POSITIVE IT WAS HANDLED WITHIN
TWENTY MINUTES --
WE BEGAN THEN LOOKING AT
REDUNDANT SYSTEMS ON TO FURTHER
STRENGTHEN OUR FLEET.
AND BECAUSE WE HAD STARTED THAT
WORK WE WERE ABLE TO OVERNIGHT
SHIP ANOTHER DEVICE WE ARE
LOOKING INTO --
I THINK THAT.
FORESIGHT BY MY STAFF AT THAT
TIME LED TO THE SUCCESSFUL
RECOVERY.
ADVOCACY NO COMPLEX.
WOULD YOU HAVE ELEVATED THAT THE
YOUR CONCERN AND THE DECEMBER
AREA TO A TIME FRAME.
UP TO MANAGEMENT OF THE PROVIDER
[inaudible]
HOME.
AT THAT TIME I THOUGHT WE DID
BECAUSE WE ARE WORKING THROUGH
OUR MAJOR ACCOUNTS --
MANAGER --
AT THAT TIME.
AND AGAIN WE WERE WORKING
TOWARDS A SOLUTION.
BASED ON OUR NEEDS.
AND BRING INDEED REDUNDANT
PROVIDERS WAS RECOGNIZED BY OUR
STAFF AS A AS A CRITICAL NEED
AND WE BEGIN IMMEDIATELY WORKING
ON THAT.
AS THE REPRESENTATIVE WITH
AMONGST A COUPLE OF YEARS WE
HAVE THE MIND OF SEEING A FIRE
I'VE HAD THE LAKE YOU NAME ALL
THE LAKE COUNTY FIRES I'VE HAD.
AT 50% OF MY LAND HAS BEEN
DESTROYED.
SO THIS IS --
DIFFICULT FOR ME BECAUSE I'M
ALWAYS GOING TO BE CONCERNED
ABOUT THE SAFETY OF MY OF FIRST
RESPONDERS PROBABLY --
THERE THEY TOPOGRAPHY.
IN MOVIES AREAS IS DIFFICULT.
AND IT IS DIFFICULT I THINK FOR
ANY PROVIDER TO GET TO SOME OF
THESE AREAS.
WITH THAT BEING SAID.
WE FOUGHT FOR LONG TIME TRYING
TO GET SOME KIND OF COVERAGE OUT
IN THESE AREAS NOT ONLY FOR THE
FIREFIGHTERS BUT PEOPLE THEY GET
STRANDED IN SOME OF THESE REALLY
DESOLATE AREAS.
AND SO --
I'M JUST A CONCERNED ABOUT WHERE
WE'RE GONNA GO FROM HERE.
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT YOU ARE
ALL SAFE.
AND AS WELL AS OUR CONSTITUENTS
ARE SAFE SO --
HOPEFULLY WE CAN COME OUT WITH
SOME KIND OF A DISCUSSION OF HOW
WE'RE GONNA FEET FIX THE
SCOREBOARD FOR YOU.
THANK YOU IS OURCAREER THEIR
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS AT THIS TIME
IS MISTER ANDREAS.
MUCH RECRUITMENT OPENING
STATEMENT SO THERE'S THERE'S
COME LIKE MOBILE COMMAND CENTERS
I TAKE IT RIGHT AND I THINK YOU
SAID THERE'S LIKE SEVEN
THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
BY CALIFORNIA OFFICE OF
EMERGENCY SERVICE AND A
DEPENDING ON THE STATE OR THE
COUNTY OR THE AGENCY THAT THERE
TO HANDLE.
IN THE ROM AND I GUESS BECAUSE
OF THAT POUNDS OR THE WAY THEY
PERFORM JUST EXIT YOUR MEDIUM
SIZE DEPARTMENT.
I'M COME FROM SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA SO I DO A LOT WITH
LIKE LA COUNTY FIRE SO THE MORE
RESOURCES AND MORE FUNDING FOR
THAT'S I GUESS IT JUST DEPENDS
ON ON THAT --
FLAG GET MORE UNDERSTANDING SO
THICK MOBILE COMMAND CENTERS IT
STRATEGICALLY PLACED WORKING IN
CONJUNCTION WITH OH YES --
DOWNLOADS DISTURB ME TALK BUT
THIS IS WHAT I GUESS THE THIRD
TIME YOU'VE HAD ISSUE WITH
PRALINE WITH --
OR WHAT THE INDUSTRY SO
OBVIOUSLY THERE ARE ISSUES THERE
I WISH.
THOSE RULE OF GOTTEN TAKING CARE
OF THE FIRST TIME RIGHT --
SO WITH THAT SAID I AM EAGER TO
HEAR MOVING FORWARD WE CAN DO TO
TO MAKE THINGS BETTER SO THIS
DOESN'T OCCUR AGAIN.
I THINK --
SOME REMEMBERING TO TALK ABOUT
THE TIME FRAME WITH THINGS.
ELECT REFER TO WHICH I SAID
EARLIER ABOUT.
EMERGENCIES HAPPEN AT ANY MINUTE
OF THE DAY I DON'T CARE FOR ITS
SUNDAY A HOLIDAY.
YOU GUYS ARE WORKING TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
YOU GUYS DON'T HAVE THE HOLIDAY.
WEEKEND HOME WITH YOUR THEIR
TIME AWAY FROM FAMILY AND
FRIENDS TO DO THE JOB AND
BECAUSE OF THAT YOU HAVE TO HAVE
EVERYTHING READY TO GO AT
MOMENTS NOTICE BECAUSE THESE
THINGS HAPPEN SECONDS.
AND THINGS CHANGE FROM MINUTE TO
MINUTE RIGHT ESPECIALLY GOT BIG
DISASTERS AND TALKING ABOUT
COVERAGE I'M MORE ONE OUT WERE
BACK IN THE FILM AND SOME OF
THESE AREAS.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE OUR MEMORY YOU
KNOW US COLLEGE WORKING
FIREPLACES OR YOU KNOW I GOT
THIS KIND OF PHONE IS NOT
WORKING I CAN'T CONNECTS OR LIKE
WHAT YOU WERE PROVIDED YOU GOT
IN YOUR WITH THREE THREE OR FOUR
OF US WE HAVE DIFFERENT PLANS
DIFFERENT PROVIDERS.
AND IT'S LIKE UP TO THAT PERSON
OKAY YEAH YOU GOT COVER JUST USE
YOUR PHONE.
IT SHOULDN'T BE THAT WAY RIGHT
IN ESTO SEES PAGLIA INITIAL LIKE
THAT IN SOME OF THESE AREAS AS
WELL YOU KNOW --
MY COLLEAGUES TALKED ABOUT THE
ROLE AREAS RIGHT THAT'S
SOMETHING WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
HOW DO WE ARE ARE IN THOSE AREAS.
AND WORKING TOGETHER PUBLIC
SAFETY BECAUSE IT'S A LOT JUST
THINK OF THAT PERSON OUT THERE
BY THEMSELVES STRANDED ON THE
SIDE OF THE ROAD --
WITHOUT OR THANK YOU ALL FOR THE
WORK YOU DO.
AND HOPEFULLY WE CAN SHARE MORE
LA SHED MORE LIGHT ON WHAT
OCCURRED AND MAKE SURE THAT.
INCIDENTS LIKE THIS DON'T OCCUR
AGAIN BECAUSE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT A FIRE.
THINK ABOUT THE BIG EARTHQUAKE
WE TALK ABOUT IT'S GOING TO
HAPPEN.
WHAT THAT'S GOING TO DO TO OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE A MAIN ROADS ARE
GONNA BE BLOCKED OF
ACCOUNTABILITY TRANSPORT
ANYTHING ANYWHERE HOW WE'RE
GONNA BE ABLE TO WORK TOGETHER?
ENOUGH THAT PRESENT ANY
CHALLENGES. TO OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE SPECIAL INCOMES
DO INTERNET CONNECTION.
SO THANK YOU FOR THE TIME
APPROACHING.
BUT BIGGEST RODRIGUEZ MISS
WALDRON.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR REALLY
GROUP BRIEFLY I MEAN THE ISSUE
ALL OF REDUNDANCY IS SO CRITICAL --
JUST FOR PERSONAL INCIDENT JUST
WAS ABOUT TWO WEEKS AGO THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS HAD ARE.
A TRIP UP TO FALL RIVER WHICH
WAS CUT SHORT --
DUE TO FIRE UP IS --
PICKED RIVER AND IT WAS
INTERESTING BECAUSE SOME OF US
WERE SEPARATED SOME OF US HAD
SELF SERVICE SOME OF US DIDN'T
AND WE HAD DIFFERENT PROVIDERS
AND ACTUALLY MUSLIM OWN AND I
HAVE THE SAME.
PROVIDER WHICH WAS ACTUALLY
WORKING WITH LIKE ONE BAR.
AND IT WOULD DROP YOU KNOW BUT
YOU COULD BUT THE ISSUES THAT WE
ENCOUNTERED NOT HAVING POWER.
SO WE COULD EVEN CHARGE OUR
PHONES WHEN THEY DIED YOU KNOW.
NOW HAVING THE REDUNDANCY THE
HARDENING OF THE ANSWER
INFRASTRUCTURE --
YOU KNOW CRITICAL AND WHAT WE
ALWAYS FOUND IN OUR INCIDENTS IS
INTER AGENCY COMMUNICATION
BECAUSE WE HAVE SO MUCH MUTUAL
AID COMING IN.
AND FOLKS NOT YOU KNOW BEING
ABLE TO COMMUNICATE EVEN IN THIS
DAY AND AGE WHICH YOU KNOW THAT
HAS TO BE A PRIORITY FOR US.
AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
THANK YOU MISS WALDRON GOT A FEW
FOLLOW UP QUESTIONS.
YOU MENTION THAT YOU GOT TO
PROVIDERS EIGHTEEN EIGHTEEN
VERIZON GIVE TO PROVIDERS ON
EVERY DEVICE OR YOU HAVE TO HAVE
DIFFERENT DEVICES [inaudible]
PROVIDERS.
I DO KNOW HOW BOTH PROVIDERS ON
EVERY DEVICE --
EVERY ONE OF OUR WILL SAY
ENGINES THE BE VARIOUS TYPES ON
WE'LL HAVE THE A WHAT WE CALL
CREE TO PUT DEVICE ON THAT CAN
HOUSE MULTIPLE --
SIM CARDS HOW WE ARE TESTING A
SINGLE PROVIDER RIGHT NOW NON.
AI DOWN TESTED FOR COVERAGE --
HOW ROBUST IS ON MAKING SURE
THAT WE DON'T HAVE THE SAME
ISSUES --
THAT WE FACED IN THE IN THE PAST
SO WE ARE CURRENTLY TESTING ON
PROVIDERS AND THEN WE WILL MOVE
TO A ROLLOUT --
FOR ALL OF OUR APPARATUS BUT I
DO WANT TO EMPHASIZE ALONE.
THE COMMENT I MADE PREVIOUSLY.
ON WE ARE CONSTANTLY HAS I
LEARNED IN THIS POSITION TRYING
TO BALANCE YOUR BUDGET TRYING TO
WORK WITHIN THE DOLLARS THAT YOU
HAVE.
IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE DO HAVE
TWO PROVIDERS FOR REDUNDANCY --
BASED ON THE SPORADIC NEED OF
OUR OWN INDUSTRY.
THAT'S DOUBLE THE COST. TO ADD
TO PROVIDERS ON BOTH ON ALL OUR
RIGS.
AND WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO FIGHT
FOR STAFFING KEEP FOR STOPPING
THAT THAT BECOMES A CHALLENGE.
CAN YOU TAKE US TO THE INCIDENT
THAT OCCURRED WHERE WAS YOUR
CREEL.
AND CAN YOU CAN YOU HOW MUCH
DETAIL CAN YOU GIVE US ABOUT
WHERE AT THE EVENT AT THE FIRE
WHERE THEY STATION.
TRYING TO DO THEIR WORK SO THIS
SUPPORT UNIT WILL OPERATE IN
BASE CAMP WHO THINK ABOUT BASE
CAMP AS A MINI CITY IF YOU WILL.
FOUND THIS IS THE FULL SUPPORT
STRUCTURE FOR THE ENTIRE
INCIDENT --
WE HAVE FINANCES LOGISTICS OF
OPERATIONS YOUR PLAN --
ALL OF THEM RELY ON CONNECTIVITY.
ON TO THE INTERNET TO PROVIDE
THE SERVICE.
AND THEY'RE CONSTANTLY WORKING
TO MAKE SURE THOSE RESOURCES ARE
TRACKED.
AND THEY'RE PUT INTO THE RIGHT
PLACES.
FINANCE TRACKING IS INCREDIBLY
IMPORTANT [inaudible]
NO.
PUTTING TOGETHER A PLAN AN
OPERATIONAL PLAN EVERY SINGLE
DAY SO WHEN THE FIREFIGHTERS GO
OUT ON THE NEXT OPERATIONAL
PERIOD.
THEY HAVE THE PLAYBOOK IF YOU
WILL AND THEY'RE ALL ON THE SAME
PAGE IT TAKES QUITE A BIT OF
WORK IN COORDINATION.
OUR UNIT IS RIGHT IN THE MIDDLE
OF THAT IT SUPPORTS THAT.
ON THIS YEAR IT IS.
BEST DESCRIBED AS A MOBILE
OFFICE ON WHEELS SO THEY PARK IT --
ITSELF SUSTAINABLE.
THEY GET INTO THE BACK OFFICE
AND BILL BE CALIFORNIA --
OFFICE OF EMERGENCY SIR --
SERVICES CHIEFS THEN THERE THAT
THEY WILL BE SUPPORTING --
IN THIS COORDINATION EFFORT.
AND SO IF YOU'RE DESCRIBING THIS
YOU HAVE.
OTHER FIREFIGHTERS OUT FIGHTING
THE FIRES RELYING ON DATA FROM
THIS UNIT.
AND WHERE THEY DELAYED IN
GETTING THE INFORMATION THEY
NEEDED.
BECAUSE THEY WEREN'T ABLE TO GET
THE IN FOR THE INFORMATION ON
HOW TO FIGHT THE FIRE.
HOW TO DEPLOY EQUIPMENT A PUSH
OUT FROM THE BASE CAMP DID DID
THAT OCCUR TO OTHER UNITS ARE
NOT JUST SANTA CLARA UNITS BUT?
OTHERS THAT YOU'RE SUPPORTING AT
THAT TIME.
LIKE I MENTIONED ALONE
PREVIOUSLY I'M I'M VERY BLESSED
TO HAVE A ON A WONDERFUL IT
STAFF AND STAFF ON THAT UNIT
THAT WERE IMMEDIATELY ABLE TO
IDENTIFY SOME WORKAROUNDS.
WHICH INCLUDE TURNING ON HOT
SPOTS ON MOBILE PHONES.
AND OVERNIGHT SHIPPING A ANOTHER
SERVICE PROVIDER THERE SO WE
WERE ABLE TO OPERATE --
WE HAD A SHORT PERIOD OF REDUCED --
DOWNTIME.
NAM BUT WE WERE ABLE TO MAINTAIN
OPERATIONS CITY DID NOT IMPACT
THE OPERATIONS OF THAT FIRE.
IN THE EARLIER THROTTLING
INCIDENT YOU TALK ABOUT HOW
QUICKLY IT WAS TO HAVE THAT
FIXED.
AND HOW THE THROTTLE IN REMOVED
YOU ABLE TO GET IN TOUCH WITH
YOUR CUSTOMER SERVICE
REPRESENTATIVE BUT IN THIS
INSTANCE THAT WAS NOT THE CASE --
WAS THERE --
AN EXPLANATION AS TO WHY THERE
WAS DELAY IN ADDRESSING THE
ISSUE THAT THAT YOU'D MENTIONED
OR OR YOU KNOW.
WAS THERE SOMETHING ELSE I WAS
TRYING TO COMMUNICATE TO YOU
FROM THE CUSTOMER SERVICE REP
HOW DID THAT WORK WORK NOT
WORKING IN THIS CASE.
SO AS I MENTIONED PREVIOUSLY WE
REACHED OUT TO OUR COUNTY
MANAGER.
CLOWN LEFT MESSAGES AND SENT A
FEW EMAILS.
ON DURING THAT TIME ALRIGHTY
OFFICER WENT THROUGH THE THE
SAME CUSTOMER SERVICE LINE THERE
THAT YOU WOULD --
FOR YOUR PROVIDER AND I'M WORKS
THROUGH THE CALL CENTRE WAS ABLE
TO REACH A TECHNICIAN.
WHO SWITCHED US TO A SLIGHTLY
HIGHER PLAN WHICH ALLEVIATED THE
THRONG ONLY THROTTLING ALTHOUGH
BRIEFLY [inaudible]
ON THE NEXT DAY I BELIEVE WE'RE
ABLE TO GET AHOLD OF THE
ACCOUNTS MANAGER --
WE'RE DIRECTED BACK TO COME TIME
WE ALREADY HAD A NEW SERVICE
PROVIDER OVERNIGHT SHIP TO AND
WAS UP AND RUNNING ON THE UNIT.
AND SO WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE
CUSTOMER SERVICE RAT --
YOU KNOW WE'RE ALL USED TO
CALLING EIGHT HUNDRED NUMBERS
WAR NOW DOING.
CHATS ONLINE ON A WEBSITE EIGHT
WITH SOMEONE THAT WE DON'T KNOW
WE DON'T REALLY KNOW WHERE
THEY'RE LOCATED WE DON'T KNOW
THEIR HIERARCHY IN AN
ORGANIZATIONAL --
STRUCTURE.
WHAT YOU KNOW WHEN YOU HAVE A
RELATIONSHIP WITH VERIZON AND
YOU'VE BEEN SOLD PLANS FOR
HUNDREDS OF --
DATA USING UNITS WHAT IS THAT
SALES CYCLE LIKE AND DO YOU KNOW
THE PEOPLE THAT YOU'RE DOING
THIS WORK WITH THE CUSTOMER
SERVICE REP THAT YOU'VE WORKED
WITH OVER TIME.
I DON'T EXPECT TO THE SERVICE
CYCLE ALONE.
BUT OUR IT STAFF DOES DEVELOP A
RELATIONSHIP --
WITH THAT REPRESENTATIVE AND WE
WORK VERY HARD.
WITH THE VARIOUS.
THE VARIOUS COMPANIES THAT WE
HAVE CONTRACTS WITH WHETHER IT
BE APPLICATION --
SOFTWARE APPLICATION FOR UNITS
OR IN THIS CASE --
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDER TO TO
COME WITH THE BEST SOLUTION FOR
OUR NEEDS AND SO YES IT IS ABOUT
RELATIONSHIPS AND BUILD NOT
STRONG RELATIONSHIPS SO THAT
THEY KNOW YOUR BUSINESS AND CAN
TALK PROVIDE YOU GUIDANCE
BECAUSE OF FOR ME IS A FIRE
CHIEF I CAN TELL YOU.
HOW TO OPERATE A FIRE DEPARTMENT?
BUT I CAN'T TELL YOU HOW TO RUN
AN INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDER.
AND WE TALKED BRIEFLY LAST NIGHT
ABOUT HOW ONE OF YOUR UNITS
COULD RUN UP EASILY A THOUSAND
DOLLAR BILL IN A MONTH BECAUSE
OF THE DATA THAT YOU'RE USING.
AND YOU'VE GOT HUNDREDS OF UNITS
SO YOU'RE YOUR BILL FOR VERIZON
IS EASILY IN THE SIX FIGURES
WHAT WOULD THAT BE I DON'T ASK
YOU TO COME WITH A NUMBER FOR
THAT ONE OF THE ON THE SPOT
WOULD THAT BE A REASONABLE
ESTIMATE OF WHAT YOUR VERIZON
DELICIOUS.
I THINK THAT MY MIND'S ONLY
SLIGHTLY LESS THAN.
I THINK THAT WAS IN THE CONTEXT
OF TOWARDS THE END OF THIS A BET
THE LAST DATA PLAN THAT WE WERE --
OFFERED --
WHICH WAS --
NINETY NINE DOLLARS A MONTH PLUS
A PER GIGABYTE CHARGE --
AND BASED ON USAGE THAT WE'RE
SEEING THAT ONE UNIT ALONG WOULD
BE ABOUT A THOUSAND DOLLARS --
SO AGAIN YOU'RE CONSTANTLY
TRYING TO FIND THAT BALANCE
BECAUSE THIS MONTH IT WOULD BE
INCREDIBLY HIGH.
NEXT MONTH GOD WILLING.
WE HAVE THE FIRES DIED DOWN.
AND WE DON'T NEED THE DATA USAGE
BUT DO YOU HAVE TO BE PREPARED
FOR THOSE SPIKES --
AND JUST ACT I THINK YOU
ANSWERED THIS BUT STILL I WANT
TO PUSH A LITTLE BIT MORE ON
THIS.
YOU'VE A VERY LARGE BILL WITH
THIS COMPANY AND THE OF A LOT OF
UNITS THAT.
PART BUT YOU KNOW HOW A SERVICE
PLAN FROM FROM VERIZON DO YOU
HAVE ONE POINT OF CONTACT AT
VERIZON IS THERE SOMEONE THAT
YOU HAVE A RELATIONSHIP WITH.
THAT WHEN YOU HAVE --
CONCERNS COMPLAINTS DATA PLAN
CHANGES THAT YOU GO TO TO
SERVICE THIS ACCOUNT.
WE TYPICALLY HAVE ONE POINT OF
CONTACT AND AND THAT WOULD BE
OUR ACCOUNTS MANAGER.
AND HOW LONG IS THAT ACCOUNTS
MANAGER BEEN YOUR POINT OF
CONTACT I WOULD HAVE TO GET BACK
TO YOU ON THAT ACCOUNTS I'M SORT
OF CHINA SPOT ABOUT THAT WHEN.
I IF IT ANY OTHER FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS ON THAT --
ANYTHING ELSE THAT YOU GUYS LIKE
TO SAY WHILE YOU'RE HERE
[inaudible]
I I JUST LIKE TO SAY THANK YOU
FOR HEARING US TODAY.
AS WITH THE ANY AGENCY WE'RE
LOOKING FORWARD TO GETTING BACK
TO THE TASK AT HAND AND THAT
SERVING.
OUR CITIZENS AND I APPRECIATE
YOUR ATTENTION TO THIS AS WE
WORK TOWARDS GOD RESOLUTION SO
THIS DOES NOT HAPPEN TO ANOTHER
FIRE AIDS.
I THINK THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
COMING HERE AND SHARING THIS
TESTIMONY YOUR WIFE WAS 1100%
CORRECT WHEN NIGHT SHE SAID THAT
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO TELL
THE STORY.
IT'S IMPORTANT FOR YOU TO SAY
THIS WEEK WE DON'T KNOW HOW HOW
MANY OTHER TIMES THIS HAS
OCCURRED AND DIED AND AND OF
COURSE IT'S ACTUALLY DID OCCUR
TO YOU BRIEFLY.
I IN A PRIOR EVENT LIGHT SIDE
BUT WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT WE
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE KNOW
ABOUT THAT'S GOING TO MAKE SURE
IT NEVER OCCURS AGAIN.
AND WE NEED TO WORK WITH SIDE
WITH THOSE WHO ARE PROVIDING
SERVICES TO OUR FIRST RESPONDERS
TO MAKE SURE.
THAT WE'VE GOT TIED THE BEST
RESPONSE POSSIBLE YOU CAN DO IT
ALONE AND DIE AND WE'RE ON THE
SAME TEAM AND I I HOPE --
YOU KNOW IT FROM THE PROVIDER'S
PERSPECTIVE THEY FEEL THE SAME
WAY.
THANK YOU ALL FIGURE.
SO NEXT I WOULD LIKE TO
INTRODUCE AN INVITE UP --
TO THAT THE TABLE DATE MISTER
DAVE HICKEY OF THE VERIZON VICE
PRESIDENT OF BUSINESS AND
GOVERNMENT SALES MISTER KEY
PLEASE COME ON AND JOIN US OUT I
SEE --
REALLY YOUTH TO JOIN US AS WELL.
AND I DON'T.
COMPLETELY NERVOUS WHY DON'T YOU
GUYS JUST GO AROUND THE TABLE
JUST INTRODUCE YOURSELVES.
FOR THAT PURPOSE [inaudible]
YEAH.
HI GOOD MORNING MISTER CHAIR
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE MY NAME
IS RUDY RAY YES I AM THE VICE
PRESIDENT OF PUBLIC POLICY.
AND ASSOCIATE GENERAL COUNSEL
FOR VERIZON IN THE WESTERN
UNITED STATES.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO COME AND
ADDRESS THE SITUATION AT HAND --
I BELIEVE YOU KNOW IT IS IN YOUR
BINDERS THIS MORNING THE COMPANY
ISSUED A STATEMENT.
A ADDRESSING --
THE SITUATION DIRECTLY AND A
WITH THE PERMISSION OF THE CHAIR
I WOULD LIKE TO READ THAT
STATEMENT IF THAT'S ALRIGHT IF
YOU COULD BURKE WHO JUST ALLOW
THE OTHER GENTLEMAN TO INTRODUCE
THEMSELVES I DON'T I DON'T KNOW
THEM I WAS GOING TO INTRODUCE
THAT OKAY.
IF THAT'S ALRIGHT WITH THE CHAIR
PERFECT THANK YOU THANK YOU.
SO THIS STATEMENT WAS ISSUED
THIS MORNING BY* SENIOR VICE
PRESIDENT OF PUBLIC SECTOR MIGHT
MARIANA.
FIRST STATE FIRST RESPONDERS PUT
THEMSELVES ON THE LINE EACH AND
EVERY DAY.
AND EVERY DAY WE ARE ETERNALLY
GRATEFUL FOR THEIR BRAVERY AND
EFFORTS.
IN SUPPORTING FIRST RESPONDERS
IN THE MENDOCINO FIRE WE DID NOT
LIVE UP TO OUR OWN PROMISE OF
SERVICE AND PERFORMANCE
EXCELLENCE WHEN OUR PROCESS
FAILED SOME FIRST RESPONDERS ON
THE LINE.
BATTLING A MASSIVE CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRE. FOR THAT WE ARE TRULY
SORRY.
AND WE'RE MAKING EVERY EFFORT TO
ENSURE THAT IT NEVER HAPPENS
AGAIN.
AS OF YESTERDAY WE REMOVED ALL
SPEED CAP RESTRICTIONS FOR FIRST
RESPONDERS ON THE WEST COAST AND
IN HAWAII. TO SUPPORT CURRENT
FIGHTER FIREFIGHTING AND
HURRICANE LANE EFFORTS.
FURTHER.
IN THE EVENT OF ANOTHER DISASTER
VERIZON WILL LIFT RESTRICTIONS
ON PUBLIC SAFETY CUSTOMERS
PROVIDING FULL NETWORK ACCESS.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING CLOSELY WITH
MISSION CRITICAL FIRST
RESPONDERS TO REFINE OUR SERVICE
PLAN TO BETTER MEET THEIR UNIQUE
NEEDS.
AS A RESULT WE'RE INTRODUCING A
NEW PLAN THAT WILL FEATURE
UNLIMITED DATA WITH NO CAPS ON
MOBILE SOLUTIONS AND
AUTOMATICALLY INCLUDES PRIORITY
ACCESS.
WILL PROVIDE FULL DETAILS WHEN
WE INTRODUCED THE PLAN NEXT WEEK.
AND WE'LL MAKE IT EASY TO
UPGRADE SERVICE AT NO ADDITIONAL
COST.
VERIZON HAS LONG BEEN KNOWN AS
THE TRUSTED PROVIDER OF CHOICE.
FOR PUBLIC SAFETY BECAUSE OF OUR
SUPERIOR NETWORK RELIABILITY AND
OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH LOCAL FIRST
RESPONDERS IN TIMES OF CRISIS.
VERIZON CUSTOMERS HAVE ACCESS TO
OUR MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED AND
FIFTY THOUSAND SQUARE MILE FOUR
G. LTE COVERAGE ADVANTAGE OVER
COMPETITORS.
IN ADDITION WE CONSISTENTLY SHOW
UP IN TIMES OF DISASTER TO
EXTEND OUR NETWORK CAPABILITIES
PROVIDE OUR CUSTOMERS WITH LONER
DEVICES AND PROVIDE CUSTOMERS OF
ANY PROVIDER.
WITH ACCESS TO FREE CHARGING
STATIONS
WE ARE PROUD TO SUPPORT THE MEN
AND WOMEN WHO SERVICE ALL.
ON A PERSONAL NOTE --
IF I MAY ADD --
AS A FIFTEEN YEAR VETERAN FOR
THE COMPANY --
WE ALL MISS WE ALL MAKE MISTAKES
FROM TIME TO TIME.
THE TRUE MEASURE OF LEADERSHIP.
IS HOW QUICKLY WE ADMIT IT
[inaudible]
OWN IT.
AND MAKE IT RIGHT.
I AM PROUD TO STAND BY THE
STATEMENT I JUST READ TO YOU.
AND I AM I HERE TO INTRODUCE --
MISTER DAVE HICKEY WHO IS OUR
VICE PRESIDENT OF OF BUSINESS
AND GOVERNMENT SALES.
WHO WILL ELABORATE FURTHER ON
THE SITUATION AT HAND HOW IT
HAPPENED AND HOW AND WHAT WE
HAVE DONE WHAT IMMEDIATE ACTION
WE'VE TAKEN TO ADDRESS THE
SITUATION AT HAND? TO HIS RIGHT
IS --
DIRECTOR WESTERN IN SHAW.
OTHER OF BUSINESS AND GOVERNMENT
SALES IN CALIFORNIA THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE.
YEAH THANK YOU MISTER A. S. AND
OUT.
AYE I WANT TO JUST ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT THE PERSONAL NOTE THAT YOU
MADE --
YOU'RE HAVING KNOWN YOU AND AND
OTHER PEOPLE THAT THAT WORK FOR
VERIZON -- I
KNOW THAT IT'S CALIFORNIANS YOU
MUST OF BEEN IS AGHAST AS
ANYBODY AND YOU SO I APPRECIATE
THE FACT THAT COME UP HERE --
TO ACKNOWLEDGE WHAT HAD OCCURRED
TO EXPRESS THE CONTRITION THAT
YOU HAVE EXPRESSED THAT THE
CORPORATION HAS EXPRESSED AS
WELL.
AND SO IT'S SAD IT'S IT'S BRAVE
OF YOU AND AND I'M I'M GRATEFUL
THAT YOU GUYS ARE HERE TO TELL
YOUR STORY AS WELL AND DIED IN
AND HELP US LEARN AS MUCH AS
POSSIBLE FROM IT MISTER ICKE.
YEAH SO THANK YOU APPRECIATE THE
TIME -- AN
ECHO MANY OF THE STATEMENTS THAT
YOU'VE SAT AND WE'VE HEARD FROM
THE OTHER COMMITTEE MEMBERS --
THROUGHOUT THIS MORNING --
ó AYE AYE IF IT'S OKAY WITH
YOU LIKE TO GO ON A LITTLE
DETAIL WHAT HAPPENED.
DEBT PLEASE THANK YOU PERFECT SO --
AS WE TAKE A STEP BACK AND
LISTEN TO WHAT WE WERE GOING
THROUGH --
AND LISTEN TO TO CHEAP OUT AND
GO THROUGH HIS --
EVENTS OF THE PROCESS --
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT WE'RE HERE
TODAY TO TALK ABOUT THIS PART OF
THE PROCESS INSTEAD OF TALKING
ABOUT PARTNERSHIP OF PUBLIC
SAFETY -- I
WILL TELL YOU AS A IT WE TOOK A
STEP.
I'M AND I THINK YOU HEARD IT
FROM THE CHIEF THAT THERE'S
OCCURRENCES WHERE WE'RE REALLY
FAST FORUM IN THIS OCCURRENCE
WHERE WENT SLOW --
AYE ARE MISTAKEN I WOULD SAY
FROM A LEADERSHIP STANDPOINT I
THINK YOU'RE THAT FROM THE
STATEMENT IS THAT YOU KNOW WE
TAKE FULL OWNERSHIP AND
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR THAT I
PERSONALLY DO AS WELL.
AND THE MISTAKE REALLY COMES
DOWN TO WE HAVE HUMAN
INTERACTION INTERVENTION THAT
WAS REQUIRED IN THE PROCESS --
AND WE ON THAT AND IT REALLY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN A SYSTEM WIDE
AUTOMATIC STEP THAT WAS ABLE TO
BE ABLE --
TO TO BE DONE WHEN WE CALL SPEED
CAPPER IN THE IN THE MEDIA SCOTT
THROTTLING AS WELL.
SO I THINK WHAT YOU'VE HEARD IS
THAT WE'VE TAKEN STEPS TO MOVE
FOR REMOVED THROUGH --
SPEAK CAPPING FROM FIRST
RESPONDER LINES --
THIS WEEK WHICH IS GREAT FOR
PEOPLE THAT ARE --
FIGHTING THE FIRES AND OTHER --
INCIDENCES THAT ARE HAPPENING
WHO I THE OTHER THING THAT WE'VE
DONE IS WE'VE TAKEN STEPS
FORWARD ON THEIR THE CALIFORNIA
CONTRACT AND OTHERS TO PUT A
PLAN IN PLACE AT NO ADDITIONAL
COST.
THAT ALLEVIATE THIS CONCERN
GOING FORWARD FOR FIRST
RESPONDERS THERE WON'T BE A DATA
CAP THAT'S ON THAT PLAN --
FROM A RESTRICTIONS STANDPOINT I
THINK THAT IN ITSELF IS A MOVE
FOR THE SECOND THING WE
INTRODUCED EARLIER THIS YEAR OUR
PRIORITY IN PREEMPTION PRODUCTS
ON SMARTPHONES AND SO NOW WHAT
CAN THIS MOBILE BROADBAND --
PRODUCT THAT THE CHIEF WAS REFER.
AND NOW HAVE PRIMARY ACCESS AS
WELL WHEN YOU GET INTO A
CONGESTED NETWORK THOSE THINGS
ALONE I THINK WILL HELP US MOVE
IN TO THE RIGHT.
ARRANGEMENT WITH FIRST
RESPONDERS SO THEY CAN DO THEIR
JOB AND CONTINUE TO STAY SAFE.
I'M I WOULD ALSO ADDRESS THAT WE
CONTINUE TO WORK TOWARDS MAKING
SURE.
HOW WE HAVE DEDICATED
INDIVIDUALS ON THE TEAMS AND
THEY UNDERSTAND HOW TO UTILIZE
THE SYSTEMS AND PROCESSES THAT
WE HAVE TODAY WE HAVE A
DEDICATED ORGANIZATION?
THAT IS A REFINED JUST DOWN TO
HANDLING GOVERNMENT
ORGANIZATIONS AS WELL WHICH IS
WHAT -- THE
CHIEF WAS ABLE TO RELY ON WHEN
HE WAS A CALLED INTO ONE OF OUR
CALL CENTERS SO THEY'RE TRAINED
THEY GO THROUGH A HEAVY
EXTENSIVE PROCESSING MONTHLY. TO
BE ABLE TO GO AND AND TAKE CARE
OF OUR CUSTOMERS ON AN
OPERATIONAL BASIS AS WELL AND
THEN -- WEST
TO MY RIGHT HERE HE ALSO HELPS
HANDLE OUR TEAMS HERE LOCALLY --
IN THE CALIFORNIA MARKET FROM A
GOVERNMENT PERSPECTIVE ACTUALLY
HANDLES THE WHOLE WEST COAST AND
THEN WE HAVE DEDICATED ACCOUNT
REPRESENTATIVES THAT WORK JUST
SOLELY ON GOVERNMENT ACCOUNTS I
KNOW YOU ASKED THAT EARLIER HOW
THAT RELATIONSHIP IS.
AND THAT'S REALLY WHERE --
THOSE CUSTOMERS ARE THERE I MEAN
THOSE REPRESENTATIVES ARE THERE
TO WORK WITH CUSTOMERS IN IT NOW
ON BE AYE CUSTOM AND BASIC
SOLUTIONS THAT THEY MAY NEED AS
YOU HEARD I THINK FROM OTHER MEN.
A CALL TO EASE OF WHAT THEY MAY
FACE IN CHALLENGES ARE DIFFERENT.
SO THOSE ARE KIND OF SOME OF THE
AREAS A AND WHAT'S I WOULD SAY
IS WHAT WE TO WHAT HAPPENED.
AND WHERE WE'VE TAKEN STEPS TO
MOVE FORWARD SO THAT IS NOT AN
OCCURRENCE GOING FORWARD.
BUT IF YOU MISTER HICKEY MISTER
SHORTAGE OF ANY COMMENTS.
GREAT THANK YOU.
MEMBERS ANY QUESTIONS AT THIS
POINT.
IF I WERE CREE.
HELLO I'M AS I SAID BEFORE TO
THE A PLUS GROUP IN RETROSPECT
IT MOVED INTO DIFFERENT.
I WOULD HAVE NOT HAD A SYSTEM IN
PLACE THERE REQUIRED --
OF RAPPER IN INTERACTION TO
REMOVE SOMETHING OFF OF
ALIGNMENT EFFORTS FROM FIRST
RESPONDERS IN THE MIDDLE OF A
CRISIS THAT WILL IT'S A LOT LAST
THING THEY SHOULD BE WORRIED
ABOUT.
IS THERE I WOULD HAVE HAD A
SYSTEM IN PLACE THAT AND
AUTOMATICALLY I UTILIZED IT
WHICH I THINK THE NEW PLANTS DO
THAT FORCE NOW IS OUR SYSTEM
THAT IN WHICH OF A FLAG ALERTS
THE A CLIENT SERVICE REP THAT.
YEAH WE MERGED CEILING NEED TO
MAKE SURE ALL LINES ARE CLEAR.
AND WHERE ARE YOU ALL RIGHT
WHERE YOU ACTUALLY AWARE OF ALL
THE DATA.
THAT THE FIRE AND OUR FIRST
RESPONERS HAVE.
IN THE BACK OF THEIR CARS
THEY'VE GOT SO MANY COMPUTERS
AND ALL THE STATE OF THIS GOING
ON AND I THINK A LOT OF US IN
LOT OF IT'S HAVE NO IDEA.
ALL THE DATA THAT IS NEEDED
DURING SPIRES AND TO SUPPRESS
THE FIRES AND MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE -- ARM
OF MUTUAL AID IN THE RIGHT
PLACES THE RIGHT TIMES AND SO I
THINK -- I
ALSO MAKE SURE THAT THE DATA CAN
CONTINUE TO FLOW BECAUSE THAT'S
A LOT OF DATA.
AND IN ITS REALLY EASY TO SAY
YEAH Y. FLIP THE SWITCHES TO GO
BUT ARE YOU REALLY READY TO TO
BE ABLE TO ACCESS AND CAN OUR
FIREFIGHTERS ACCESS THAT IDEA.
THE IF I MAY SIR GREAT GREAT
QUESTION --
I THINK PRETTY SAID IT PASSED
EARLIER WE HAVE A LONG STANDING
HISTORY OF WORKING WITH PUBLIC
SAFETY WHAT THAT IS THE
ADVANTAGE THAT IS GIVEN US.
AS WE UNDERSTAND WHAT'S
HAPPENING ON THE FRONTLINE AND
SO WE HAVE A TEAM OF THESE
THIRTEEN THAT GOES OUT AND WORK
SIDE BY SIDE WITH THESE
INDIVIDUALS.
I'M I HAVE SOME I THINK THIS AS
SHE COULD BE POTENTIALLY IN YOUR
BINDERS AS WELL AS THERE'S MANY
THINGS IN WHICH WE'VE DEPLOYED
NOW JUST GIVE YOU AN IDEA MAYBE
ELABORATE WHEN YOU SAY EQUIPMENT --
ON IT SO --
THEY HAVE EVERYTHING FROM --
MOBILE PHONES AND TABLETS AND
AND ROUTERS IN PLACE AND
SPECIALIZED EQUIPMENT AND AND
THEN OFTEN THEY FIND THEMSELVES
IN RURAL SITUATIONS WHERE THEY
NEED ADDITIONAL COVERAGE WE WILL
ROLL OUT --
CALVIN COLDS THOSE ARE PRETTY
MUCH BRINGING OUT A CELL TOWER
ON WHALES IN BEING ABLE TO
DEPLOY THOSE FOR YOU AS WELL I
WILL TELL YOU IN THE MENDOCINO
COMPLEX FIRE.
WE AT THIRTY EIGHT SITES THAT
WERE IMPACT 7% CELL SITE
AVAILABILITY --
WITHIN THAT FOR THE FOURTEEN
DAYS WE'VE HAD A HUNDRED PER HOW
2% SINCE THEN WHAT THAT TELLS ME
IS WE REALLY TOOK I THINK IT WAS
THE QUESTION EARLIER ABOUT WHAT
HAVE YOU DONE TO HELP.
PREVENT CELL SITES FROM --
FACING DESTRUCTION SO WE REALLY
TAKE PRIDE IN THE WAY WE MANAGE
OUR NETWORK FROM THAT STANDPOINT
AS WELL -- I
WOULD ALSO TELL YOU THAT WE HAVE
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE ON THE
GROUND THAT ARE DELIVERING ON
EVERYTHING FROM CELLPHONES
ROUTERS HOT SPOTS INTERNET
CONNECTED LAPTOPS.
CHARGING STATIONS RAP --
FOR THE RED CROSS STATIONS AS
WELL HELPING THOSE THAT HAVE
BEEN EVACUATED IN PROVIDING THEM
CAN ACTIVITY SO WE'VE ADDED
CAPACITY TO SITES AS WE SEE THEM
FIT WITHIN THOSE RANGES SO AS AN
INCIDENT HAPPENS.
WE WILL DIRECT TRAFFIC OR DIRECT
CAPACITY TO THOSE SITES WHERE
NEEDED ARE AT AS LONG AS THE
SITUATION ARISES SO I THINK
THAT'S THAT'S A WAYS FROM WHERE
WE STAND WE TRY TO GET
PROACTIVELY AHEAD OF IT.
SO AS YOU CAN IMAGINE I'VE BEEN
NUMEROUS FIRES THE PAST. THREE
YEARS YEAH.
AND I APPRECIATE THE EFFORT TO
BRING OUT THE MOBILE --
THE RISE IN CELLS YOU KNOW
SITTING RIGHT.
UNFORTUNATE SOMETIMES THEY SIT
THERE FOR A COUPLE DAYS BEFORE
SOMEONE'S ACTUALLY AFTER TO
ACTIVATE HIM.
SO I WOULD JUST SUGGEST THAT WE
MAKE SURE HAVE THAT --
THAT WOULD BE VERY HELPFUL --
AND THEN THE OTHER THING IS I
ALWAYS HAVE TO GO BACK FROM
EVERYBODY IN THE BUILDING KNOWS
I'M I'M FROM A RURAL AREA.
AND I APPLAUD YOU FOR WHAT
YOU'VE DONE FOR PUBLIC SAFETY
BUT I WANT YOU TO MAKE SURE YOU
DON'T FORGET ABOUT THE RURAL
AREAS BECAUSE THEIR VOICE IS NOT
NECESSARY HEARD THEY DON'T HAVE
THE EXPERTISE NECESSARY HELP
IMPLEMENT AND GET GRANTS TO GET.
SOME OF THE FUNDING TO DO SOME
OF THESE THINGS AND
UNFORTUNATELY RIGHT NOW WHERE WE
HAVE THE CAMPFIRES FARTHER RURAL
AREAS NOT THAT DOESN'T HAPPEN OR
URBAN AREAS BUT KEEP THAT IN
MIND AS AS WE MOVE FORWARD.
AND I APPRECIATE THE MOMENTUM IN
THAT WITH THE LETTER TODAY AND
WHAT YOU PLAN ON DOING --
BUT WE ALWAYS CAN IMPROVE AND SO
WHAT WE DO TODAY --
I'M HOPING THAT MAYBE IN SIX
MONTHS SO WE CAN REVIEW IT WHAT
WORKED WHAT DIDN'T WORK SUB
THANK YOU VERY LACKEY
[inaudible]
MISTER RODRIGUEZ.
YES ALSO ARE RUDY ON A THANK YOU
FOR READING THAT STATEMENT AND
RICE AND TAKING THE QUICK ON A
SHIP IN ADDRESSING IT MERELY
THAT THE ISSUE THAT OCCURRED IN
THE FIRE --
SO THANK YOU FOR RIGHTS AND FOR
IMMEDIATELY WORKING OUT ON A FIX
TO THE SOLUTION.
I JUST HAVE TWO QUESTIONS --
WE TALKED ABOUT SOME ISSUES WHEN
THEY TALKED ABOUT.
TRYING TO GET A HOLD OF SOMEBODY
TO UP THE PLANET SHE WITH ISSUES
SO.
MORE ARE THERE CALL CENTERS
LOCATED FOR THEM FIRST
RESPONDERS ARE THEY LOCATED.
HERE IN CALIFORNIA AND ARE THEY
REALLY EASY ACCESSIBLE.
I THINK YOU SAID YOU HAVE
DEDICATED PERSONNEL SO. ONE
QUESTION IS WHERE THEY LOCATED
IN THE REALLY EASY ACCESSIBLE TO
THEM. TWENTY FOUR HOURS SEVEN
DAYS A WEEK JUST LIKE THEY WORK
TWENTY FOUR HOURS SEVEN DAYS A
WEEK.
FOR ONE AND FOR TWO OF THE CHIEF
TALKED ABOUT THIS WAS LOOKS LIKE
THAT THIRD TIME.
THERE IS AN ISSUE WHY WASN'T
ANYTHING REALLY LOOKED AT THE
FIRST TIME WORKING WITH THEM TO
MAKE SURE THAT DIDN'T HAPPEN
AGAIN SO THE ONLY TO QUESTION
THAT GREAT AYE.
SO WE DO HAVE CALL CENTERS --
ACROSS THE COUNTRY THAT ARE DE
DESIGNATED --
SEPARATELY FROM CONSUMER AND
BUSINESS AND THEY'RE TRAINED ON
HOW TO TAKE CARE OF CUSTOMERS --
AS WELL WHICH IS HOW THE THAT
THE OCCURRENCE WHERE THAT YOU
SPOKE ABOUT THE TWENTY MINUTES
AND BEING ABLE TO MOVE HE'D I
WORKED THROUGH ONE OF THOSE
CENTERS.
AND A WRAP.
OF REPRESENTATIVES UP THERE THAT
DEAL WITH I WOULD SAY MORE OF
THESE ISSUES OF A FREQUENTLY THE
OTHER PART OF THAT SUPPORT COMES
FROM WE HAVE LOCAL MAJOR ACCOUNT
MANAGERS ACROSS THE COUNTRY.
THAT ARE ASSIGNED SPECIFIC --
EITHER BASED ON OUR BEING ABLE
TO SUPPORT THAT TERRITORY AS
WELL AND THEN THEY BECOME THAT --
THE NAME IN THE FACE OF A
VERIZON AND WORK THROUGH WHETHER
THAT BE SERVICE ISSUES AND ALSO
TAKING CARE OF ME OUR FUTURE
SOLUTIONS SO THAT'S KIND OF HOW
THAT THAT THE SERVICE --
SIDE OF IT --
WORKS AS WELL THE SECOND PART OF
YOUR QUESTION WAS THE CHIEF
ELABORATE ELABORATED ABOUT AN
INCIDENT DECEMBER ó AFFRONT TO
GO ABOUT.
IT YEAH BROADLY NEW ISSUES I'M
JUST PERSON HOW COME THERE WAS
AND MAYBE A MORE --
EAGER RESPONSE TO TAKE CARE THAT
THEN.
YEAH AT THAT TIME THERE ARE NOW
VALID QUESTION FOR SURE AS WELL
I I WOULD TELL YOU THAT.
THAT THE PLAN AND WATCHED --
THE CHIEF AND OTHERS HAVE
REFERRED --
TO THAT WAS THAT I WOULD SAY
THAT WAS THE OPTION ON IT WAS IN
A POLICY THAT WAS JUST PART OF
THAT PRICE PLAN.
AND THEN IN INCIDENTS WHICH WE
GOT TALKED ABOUT --
LIKE THE CHIEF OCCURRED THAT
THAT IS SUPPOSED TO BE REMOVED
IF I GO BACK TO WHAT I EARLIER
SAID THERE WAS AN OPERATIONAL
AIR -- AND
AND YOU KNOW WE WE FELT ON THAT
PART OF IT AND IT SHOULD HAVE
BEEN REMOVED ACT GOING FORWARD --
IT'S UNFORTUNATE THAT OF THAT
LIKE THIS BRINGS US TOGETHER BUT
I THINK THAT THE FACT THAT
MATTER I THINK IT --
THE RESOLUTION IS GOING TO HELP
EVERYBODY ELSE --
AS WE GO FORWARD IN THAT AND I
THINK THAT'S THANK YOU YEAH.
IT'S WALDRON.
THANK YOU HOME JUST FOR
CLARIFICATION SO --
THE PUBLIC SAFETY ACCOUNTS WILL.
ALWAYS HAVE THE CAP LIVED IF
THEY DON'T HAVE TO GO ON AN
INCIDENT BY INCIDENT FISHER OKAY
YES FIRST FIRST RESPONDERS FOR
FIRST RESPONDERS WILL HAVE THAT
CAP REMAIN IS REMOVED AND IT'S
ALREADY REMEMBER RIGHT NOW AND
THEN THE THE NEW PLAN WILL BE IN
PLACE NEXT WEEK AS IT.
GETS SICK KNOWLEDGE STE ARE BY
EACH AGENCY.
OKAY AND THEN --
JUST TO COME FOLLOW UP WITH THEM
WHAT MISS AGUIAR-CURRY WAS
SAYING --
AND YOU KNOW IT'S A RELATIVE ALL
OVER THE STATE IN A LOT OF OUR
DISTRICTS.
WITH REMOTE BACKCOUNTRY AIR
TRIBAL LANDS.
M. THEY ALSO HAVE THEIR OWN
PUBLIC SAFETY NOW SOME OF THEM
NOT ALL OF THEM SOME OF THEM ARE
VERY REMOTE --
TRYING TO GET ACCESS INTO THEIR
IS CRITICAL AS IT IS --
HOW DO YOU DRESS THAT YOU STILL
HAVE THE SAME TYPES OF
AGREEMENTS WITH THE TRIBAL --
DIFFERENT PUBLIC SAFETY GROUPS
AS WELL.
SO WE WE HAVE A AS YOU MY
REALIZE AT THAT THE COMPANY OF
OUR SIZE WE HAVE A DEDICATED
NETWORK ORGANIZATION.
AND THEY'RE REALLY OUT AND TASK
WITH A FEW THINGS THAT ONE IS
ENSURING THE COVERAGE THAT WE
HAVE IN PLACE HAS CAPACITY TO
HANDLE THE TRAFFIC.
A AND THOSE THAT ARE USING THE
AND FUTURE PROOF IT AS WELL THE
OTHER PART OF THAT IS LOOKING
FOR AREAS --
TO WHERE WE CAN IMPROVE COVERAGE
AND PROVIDE THAT --
FOR THE POPULATION THAT MAYBE
DEMAND YOU KNOW THAT AS WELL AS
WE CONTINUE TO ROLL THROUGH --
MANY CYCLES OF THAT AND AND AND
GROW IN AND I THINK RUDY SAID
EARLIER -- I
THINK IT'S ONE THING --
YOU COULD PROBABLY SURVEY MOST
VERIZON CUSTOMERS OUT THERE AS
WELL WE DO PRIDE OR SELF FROM A
NETWORK STANDPOINT.
OF FOREIGN --
FIFTY THOUSAND STE.
THAT'S NOT A PROCESS THAT
HAPPENED OVERNIGHT AND TOOK
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT FOR US TO
TELL HIM AND I AND I GIVE YOU
OUR COMMITMENT THAT'S SOMETHING
WE WILL CONTINUE TO WORK ON AS
WE DO I WOULD SAY YOUR ACCOUNT
REPRESENTATIVES.
TO THEY'VE THEY BRING THOSE ARM
THOSE AREAS OF CONCERN WHETHER
BE LACK OF COVERAGE OR CAPACITY
UP THROUGH US IN THE MEANWHILE
THAT THROUGH OUR NETWORK
PROTOCOL.
THANK YOU ENDS YEARS WAS ONE OF
THE NETWORKS THAT WAS WORKING IN
THE FALL RIVER FIRE THANK YOU.
BUT OBVIOUSLY NOT.
I THINK YOU --
YOU KNOW BUT WE'RE HERE DEFINITE
HERE TODAY TO TALK ABOUT THE
SPECIFIC ISSUE AND IT'S BEEN
MENTIONED THAT --
IT'S WE KNOW BEEN. THREE
INCIDENTS BUT IN THINKING MORE
OF WAYS --
THAT WOULD HELP US MOVE FORWARD
THAT WOULD.
ALSO LOOK BEYOND THE INCIDENT
THAT WE'RE HERE TO DISCUSS BUT
CAN YOU TALK ABOUT WHAT VERIZON
TYPICALLY.
A WHAT ACTIVITIES REYES AND
TYPICALLY ENGAGES IN WHEN
PRESENTED WITH.
WILDFIRE SITUATIONS IN
CALIFORNIA AND DOES IT VERY
REGION TO REGION COUNTY TO
COUNTY BUT WHAT ARE WHAT ARE THE
THINGS THAT YOU TYPICALLY ENGAGE
A YEAH IT A GREAT GREAT QUESTION --
I WOULD SAY STEMS BACK TO A FEW
AREAS WINE AT THINK IT STARTS
WITH THE PARTNERSHIP THAT WE
WOULD HAVE WITH THE AGENCIES
ACROSS CALIFORNIA --
FOR INSTANCE AND UNDERSTANDING
THE SIGNIFICANT NEED FOR
SERVICES OUTSIDE OF I WOULD SAY
STANDARD PROTOCOL AS WELL AND SO
WE HAVE --
WE HAVE AN ENGINEER ON THEIR
NETWORK SIDE THIS IT'S AND
EMERGENCY OFFICE AS WELL WHILE
CRISIS IS ARE GOING THRU SO U.
S. THERE WHICH IS I. HELPS US TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT WE NEED TO
DEPLOY --
AND THEN WE HAVE OF THESE
THIRTEEN THAT'S DE. FOR INDIA
THAT HAS --
VEHICLES AND TRAILERS AND THINGS
SET UP THROUGHOUT THE STATE TO
DEPLOY IT NOT ONLY NETWORK
RESOURCES BUT ALSO QUITMAN
LAPTOPS AND PEOPLE.
OUGHT TO BE ABLE --
TO HELP IN AND OUT THROUGH THE
WILD FIRES AS WELL AND THEN AS
INCIDENTS HAPPEN --
AS GO FORWARD WE LOOK AT
REDIRECTING ARE MAKING SURE WE
HAVE THE CAPACITY AT THE SITE
AND THEN --
ENSURING THAT THE RIGHT --
THE RIGHT PROCESSES ARE ABLE TO
FOLLOW IN AND FORTUNE LIKE IN
THIS INCIDENT --
ALONE AND THAT PROCESS WAS NOT
ABLE TO BE FOLLOWED BECAUSE OF I
THINK THE HUMAN SIDE OF AND AND
AND WE'VE NOW TAKEN THAT PIECE
OUT.
I TO MAKE IT A SYSTEM WIDE EYES
STANDPOINT SO THAT FIRST
RESPONDER DOES NOT NEED TO WORRY
ABOUT THAT.
THANK YOU AND ADDITIONALLY
YOU'VE A VIEW RELEASED A
STATEMENT NOT JUST THAT YOU YOU
HAD THE OPPORTUNITY TO US TODAY
BUT THE RELEASED THE PUBLIC
ABOUT YOUR WORK.
MOVING FORWARD THAT CAN YOU TALK
A LITTLE BIT --
OR MAYBE GIVE US A TEASER ABOUT
WHAT THAT PLAN THAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN THIS STATEMENT
MY INCLUDE.
ABSOLUTELY YET SO --
FOR THAT SHE FOR INSTANCE IS ON
A AT THE KEY REFERENCE TO THIRTY
SEVEN NINETY NINE PLAN THAT HE
WAS CURRENTLY ON THAT PLAN RATE
WISE WILL STAY THE SAME WHAT HE
WILL GET NOW IS THE AT FULL
ACCESS TO OUR NETWORK WITH NO
SPEED CAPS.
AND THEN THE LAB DATA PRIORITY
ACCESS AS WELL WHICH IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT FOR PUBLIC SAFETY AS
NETWORKS BECOME CONGESTED IN A
CRISIS EVENT.
ON THAT THEY WILL HAVE --
THAT BE ABLE TO GET THROUGH
THERE AND AND BE ABLE TO LEAVE
UTILIZE IT AT THE RIGHT SPEED.
SO THAT'S WHAT THAT AT THAT PLAN
WILL HELP US IN CONJUNCTION WITH
THE OTHER THINGS THAT WE DID
BACK EARLIER IN APRIL AROUND
SMARTPHONES ME THANK YOU AND I
WANNA ECHO I THINK WHAT.
WE'VE HEARD I'M FROM ALL OF OUR
COLLEAGUES IS THAT --
THE ISSUES ABSOLUTELY WORRY ES
UM AND WE WANT TO TRY TO FIND A
WAY AND THAT WE CAN WORK IN
PARTNERSHIP --
BUT I ALSO HOPE AND AND IN WHILE.
YOU LIAM AS RISE IN ARE THE
FOCUS TODAY THAT THIS
CONVERSATION IS NOT UNDERSTOOD
AS JUST LIMITED I'M TO VERIZON
BUT REALLY ABOUT.
IF WE'RE MOVING FORWARD HOW DO
WE MOVE FORWARD I'M IN A
DIFFERENT WAY I'M REALLY WITH
ALL OF TELECOMMUNICATIONS
BECAUSE IT SOUNDED TO ME THAT
WHILE THERE WERE MISTAKES IT WAS
ALSO VERY EVIDENT.
THAT OUR PUBLIC SAFETY CAN'T
LIVE WITHOUT THE PRODUCTS AND SO
THAT IS PART OF THE NECESSITY TO
TRY TO FIGURE OUT HOW TO MOVE
FORWARD -- I
KNOW IT'S ALSO VERY COMPLICATED
ON AUGUST NINTH --
I WAS IN LASSEN COUNTY AND I GOT
EVACUATED ON FOR A FIRE.
AYE AND IF THERE WAS A MOMENT
WHERE I HAD.
MY SON WAS THE ONLY ONE THAT WAS
WORKING AND MULTIPLE PEOPLE WERE
FIRING THE PHONE AND IT HAPPENED
TO BE THAT I'M I AM A CUSTOMER
OF YOURS.
SO IT'S COMPLICATED WE THINGS
MIGHT HAVE AND BUT I WOULD
REALLY HOPE THAT WHAT COMES OUT
OF TODAY IS NOT JUST.
A FOCUS ON ONE COMPANY BUT A WAY
FOR ALL OF US TO MOVE FORWARD TO
SAY THAT FOR EVERY COMPANY TO
KNOW THAT THIS IS SOMETHING THAT
IS IMPORTANT TO S. --
IT IS IS SOMETHING THAT IS OUR
NEW NORMAL AS THE GOVERNOR HAS
DESCRIBED IT SO WE WANT TO
ENSURE THAT WE NEVER.
UMP PUBLIC SAFETY OR THE PEOPLE
OF CALIFORNIA IN A PLACE --
WHERE THE --
MEAL FOR THOSE MINUTES AND
SECONDS COUNT AND THAT
COMMUNICATION IS VITAL TO IT AND
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
QUICK [inaudible]
SPONSORS AND TO THIS SET UP
PROBLEM I THINK THAT THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT DOES NOT --
GO UNNOTICED TO THAT THE
RESPONSE WAS VERY QUICK TO TRY
TO RECTIFY A PROBLEM I KNOW THAT
WE CAN'T ALWAYS --
YOU KNOW PLAN.
CREATE A LAWLER POLICY.
FOR HUMAN ERROR IT'S HARD IT'S
REALLY HARD EVEN HAPPENS AMONGST
US ON BUT IT IS SO WE HAVE
REFEREE.
HUNGRY LIKE I PRESSED THE WRONG
BUTTON LET ME GO BACK AND FIX IT.
AND AND IT'S JUST IT'S IMPORTANT
TO RECOGNIZE AGAIN IT'S NOT
LIMITED TO YOU BUT WE READ THIS
IS.
IT WAS IMPORTANT ENOUGH FOR ALL
OF US TO BE HERE IN THIS ROOM TO
HAVE THIS CONVERSATION AND TO
UNDERSTAND HOW WE MOVE FORWARD.
A I DO WELCOME THAT IF THERE ARE
ADDITIONAL CONVERSATIONS THAT
NEED TO HAPPEN OUTSIDE OF THIS
PARTICULAR HEARING CONVERSATIONS
THAT NOT ONLY INFORM HOW WE MOVE
FORWARD BUT THAT MAYBE CHANGE
THE WAY WE MOVE FORWARD.
AND TO HELP PUBLIC SAFETY I KNOW
THAT I WOULD BE INTERESTED IN
HAVING THOSE CONVERSATIONS IF WE
HAVE LEARN BEST PRACTICES THAT
SHOULD BE EXAMINED THAT SHOULD
BE LOOKED AT IN A WAY THAT THIS
WILL NOT BE. FIVE OR TEN YEARS
WE WANNA KNOW THOSE BECAUSE WE
WANT TO KNOW HOW WE REPLICATE
THEM ACROSS THE STATE.
AND I I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE --
TO YOU KNOW BE EVACUATED NOT
JUST IN SANTA BARBARA MATURE
COUNTY BUT NOW AND RURAL --
YOU KNOW VERY VERY RURAL --
PART OF CALIFORNIA AND THAT'S
HARDER --
DAY THERE IS.
THERE ARE SOME OTHER HARDSHIPS
THERE AND SO I THINK THAT AS WE
HAVE THOSE CONVERSATIONS --
I HOPE YOU WILL BE AT THE TABLE
IT LOOKS LIKE YOU'RE GONNA GET
TABLE IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU'RE
GONNA BE AT THE TABLE ON AND I
THINK YOU FOR THAT --
FIT FOR THAT RESPONSE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
WHEN QUESTIONED EMISSARY HURRY?
I JUST AYE CURIOSITY'S SAKE DOES
OFF THE ROADS TO SERVICES HAVE
ONE MANAGE PLAN THAT THEY CAN
WORK WITH YOU ON IT SEEMS TO ME
IS THE FOR HAVING A EACH ONE OF
THESE INDIVIDUAL.
FIRE DEPARTMENTS AND HAVE WILL
OFFICE EMERGENCY SERVICES WOULD
YOU THINK THEY SHOULD HAVE A
CONTRACT.
YEAH YOU MAY ALREADY HAVE THAT
ARE NEW YES I'VE GOT A GREAT
QUESTION SO YOU MAY NOT BE AWARE
THAT THAT'S THE STATE NEGOTIATES
A CONTRACT THAT HAS.
SPECIFIC PLANS THAT ALIGN WITH
CERTAIN PRODUCTS SO THAT THAT IS
THE SITUATION TODAY THE GREAT
THING ABOUT THE NEW PLAN GOING
FORWARD ABSOLUTELY --
MAKES THE CHOICE MUCH EASIER POP
FOR THAT TYPE OF PLAN
[inaudible]
BUT SEE IN THIS STATEMENT WHERE
YOU'VE TALKED ABOUT LIFTING OF
THE CAPS IN THE SPEED
RESTRICTIONS FOR FIRE FIGHTING
CALIFORNIA.
EFFECTIVE IMMEDIATELY AND FOR
HURRICANE LANE IN WHO I THAT
WITH THE PLAN THAT YOU'RE.
PLANNING ON INTRODUCING NEXT
WEEK AND EVEN INCLUSIVE OF WHAT
YOU'RE DOING RIGHT NOW.
BUT BUT THE PLAN NEXT WEEK IS
NOT GOING TO BE NATIONWIDE IS
THAT CALIFORNIA'S SPECIFIC AND
YOU KNOW THERE ARE WILD FIRES
GOING ON ACROSS THIS COUNTRY.
ARE BEYOND JUST CALIFORNIA OR
THE EXHAUSTION DISASTER IN L. Y. --
THAT THIS COULD APPLY TO AND SO
HOW HOW MUCH ARE YOU TAKING THAT
NATIONWIDE LOOK DIED AT THIS
WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING AT BITING
THIS APPLE AND AND KIND OF
FICTION IS NOT ABSOLUTE THIS SO
THIS IS A NATIONWIDE --
FIRST RESPONDER POLICY THAT'S
GOING INTO EFFECT.
AND AND SO THAT THE PLAN WOULD
APPLY THAT WAY.
SO ACT FRIENDLY SWINGS WILL HAVE
TO GO THROUGH THEIR THEIR
CONTRACT VEHICLE AND ACKNOWLEDGE
BUT AS SOON AS THEY DO THAT
THEY'LL BE ABLE TO MOVE OVER TO
THAT.
SO YOU GOT A LOOK AT THE
CONTRACT VEHICLE TO UNDERSTAND
WHO YOUR ACCOUNT IS WITH SO HOW
CERTAIN ARE YOU THAT YOU KNOW
WHO ARE YOUR FIRST RESPONDER.
ACCOUNTS ARE YET SO I THOUGHT WE
HAVE THE IDENTIFIED THROUGH --
A TWO IT'S CALLED MAX CODES IN
THESE CODES IDENTIFY WHO FIRST
RESPONDERS ARE AND THAT'S WHAT
OUR SYSTEM UTILIZES I'VE TO
ENSURE THAT WE CAN GO THROUGH
AND MAKE SURE THEY'RE PUT ON
THOSE RIGHT PLANS ARE GOING FOR
IT AND THAT'S ACROSS THE ENTIRE
NATION.
AND AND SO YOU'VE GOT THIS
IDENTIFIER IT TELLS YOU WHO YOUR
CUSTOMER IS.
DEED I MEAN I AGAIN I I HATE
PUTTING PEOPLE ON THE SPOT I
MEAN YOU KNOW HOW MANY OF OF
THOSE ARE IN CALIFORNIA TODAY
ONE IN.
THE NUMBER OF ACCOUNTS BUT THEN
THE NUMBER OF DEVICES THAT THIS
CHANGE WOULD BE AFFECTING.
ARM AND IT'S IT'S YOU KNOW I'M
TEMPTED.
WE PUBLIC I SOUNDS LIKE TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF DEVICES AT THE
LEAST AND HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
YOU KNOW IF YOU STARTING ABOUT.
HOW MANY AGENCIES WE HAVE IN THE
STATE BOTH ON FIRE FIGHTING BUT
LAW ENFORCEMENT THAT OUR
EMERGENCY RESPONDERS ALL AGENTS
[inaudible]
IN CALIFORNIA [inaudible]
PLUS PUB. FOUR HUNDRED THOUSAND
RANGE OKAY BETH THANK YOU PUBLIC
SAFETY IS AS A PERSON
[inaudible]
OKAY.
I'M WHEN YOU WHEN YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT -- AT
THIS SPEED RESTRICTIONS SO YOU
GOT THE SPEED CAP [inaudible]
A TERM THAT I THINK IS.
EASIER TO UNDERSTAND AND
THROTTLING --
THAT.
YOU ALSO MENTIONED THAT THEY
WOULD BE GETTING THE BEST
TRAFFIC.
WHICH TO ME SOUNDS LIKE OP
PRIORITIZATION OF THE TRAFFIC
FOR THESE FIRST RESPONDER
ACCOUNTS.
AND SO IT'S LIKE HAVING --
YOU KNOW I DEDICATED LANE.
ON THE HIGHWAY FOR FIRST FIRST
RESPONDERS IS THAT ESSENTIALLY
WHAT IT IS.
YOU JUST YOU DESCRIBED IT
PERFECTLY OKAY SO ON THAT'S IT'S
GREAT TO KNOW HAN ANSWERED AS
THIS EXISTED IN THE PAST OR IS
THIS SOMETHING NEW THAT YOU'RE
ABLE TO IMPLEMENT.
SO DO I WE ARE A LAUNCH THIS
PRODUCT EARLIER THIS YEAR ON OUR
SMARTPHONE SYSTEM AND THEN WE'D --
I THINK AS RUDY MENTIONED IN THE
STATE AND BEEN WORKING --
IN THE PROCESS TO BRING FORTH
THIS SORT OF PROGRAM ON OUR DATA
SIDE OF IT FOR MOBILE BROADBAND
SPECIFICALLY LIKE ROUTERS --
THAT HER MOBILE AND THESE TYPE
OF UNIT SO THAT'S THAT'S WHERE
THAT SYSTEM JUST LAUNCHED IN I
THINK THAT THE MOBILE BROADBAND
PIECE OF IT LAUNCHED IN THE LAST
I THINK IT WILL ONCE IN THE LAST
MONTH AND A HALF --
FOR THAT SORT OF ITS SMARTPHONES
BACK IN APRIL OKAY SO SWITCHES
ARE IN FLIPPED YES FIRST
RESPONDERS AND WE TALKED A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW MANY.
I DEVICES IN AN ACCOUNT THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE BUT HOW DO YOU DEFINE
FIRST RESPONDER.
HOW DO YOU FIGURE OUT WHAT NEEDS
THAT CODE --
OR CODES THAT DO THAT I HAVE
THAT LABEL HERE BUT WE HAVEN'T
WE HAVEN'T LEGAL DOWN --
TO FIRE FIRST RESPONDERS.
A PUBLIC SAFETY WEB POLICE FIRE
EMERGENCY SERVICE SAYS THE
JUSTICE DEPARTMENT FBI AND THOSE --
SECRET SERVICE DOUBTS FIRST
RESPONDER OFF --
AND OVERALL AND THAT YOU HAVE
PUBLIC SAFETY I IN GENERAL THAT
COVERS THE REST THAT WOULD BE
BACK OFFICE AND WITH THAT
INCLUDING.
PUBLIC --
AGENCY AMBULANCES OR EVEN
PRIVATE SECTOR AMBULANCE
SERVICES YES --
AT AT ALL TIMES NOT JUST IN A
DISASTER AND GODLY YES.
AND DIE IN SO YOU YOU MENTIONED
THAT.
YOU KNOW YOU'VE MADE THESE.
CHANGES FOR THIS CURRENT
FIREFIGHTING MOMENT IN TIME THIS
WEEK WE DON'T THE PLAN IS NEXT
WEEK AND HOW YOU.
SHIFT ALL THESE ACCOUNTS TO THAT
NEXT PLAN AND WHAT THE PEOPLE
WORKING PHONE CALLS AND APPROVAL
PROCESSES THAT ALL THESE
DIFFERENT PUBLIC AGENCIES MAY
HAVE. TO GET TO THAT BUT FOR
WHAT YOU'VE DONE THIS WEEK WHICH
I IMAGINE WOULD CONTINUE ON
UNTIL YOU'RE ABLE TO HELP
TRANSITION PEOPLE ABSOLUTE TO
THOSE NEW PLANTS --
SEEMS.
IN IN -- IN
THE ANNOUNCEMENT THAT YOU MADE
IN AGAIN THANK YOU FOR FOR THE
ANNOUNCEMENT AND THE CONTRITION --
NOTED IN IT THAT --
IT IS DISASTER CONTINGENT.
SO HOW DO YOU DEFINE.
WHAT DOES DISASTROUS MIGHT BE
AND AND SINCE WILD FIRES ACROSS
THE STATE IS ESSENTIALLY?
THE CITY CALIFORNIA IT'S JUST
DONE FOR CALIFORNIA AND HAWAII --
BORDERS IT A LITTLE BIT MORE
SPECIFIC THAN THAT AND THEN HOW
DO YOU DEFINE IT WE WE LOOK AT
NATURAL DISASTERS --
CLEARLY WE AND ARMS AROUND HOW.
TO REACT TO THE ONES YOU HAVE NO
NOTICE TWO VERSES ARE HURRICANE
WHERE YOU MAY HAVE TIME --
TO TO GO THROUGH THAT SITES WERE
EVALUATING BOTH SIDES OF THE
FENCE THERE AS WELL AND THEN
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S MANY
SITUATIONS WE HAVEN'T THOUGHT
THROUGH.
ARE THAT ARE OUT THERE THAT --
OUTSIDE OF FIRE THAT CAN BE
POLICE DRIVEN I WAS SHOOTER
SITUATIONS AND STUFF LIKE THAT
SO THE GREAT PART IS THAT GO OUT
WITH FIRST RESPONDERS.
THERE IT WON'T MATTER ABOUT THE
INCIDENT ITSELF BECAUSE THEY
WILL ALREADY HAVE THAT ABILITY
TO USE THAN THE NETWORK THAT WE
WANT TO GO THROUGH THAT PROCESS.
IT'S MORE OF FOR BACK OFFICE --
ADAM I WOULD SAY THAT THEY'RE
THE PEOPLE THAT COULD BE
POTENTIALLY NOT OUT ON THE
FRONTLINE THAT COULD HAVE THAT
PROCESS THEY NEED TO GO THROUGH
SO YOU'RE.
I UNDERSTAND YOU'RE SAYING IT'S
NOT SOME THAT WE NEED TO WORRY
ABOUT BUT THERE IS SOME TYPE OF
CRITERIA FOR THE CONSIDERATION
OF WHAT IS A DISASTER.
AND WHO DO YOU WORK WITH TO
DEFINE.
WHAT THOSE CRITERIA MIGHT BE AND?
TO GET TO THAT POINT YOUR HEART
NOT IN IT YEAH TRYING TO FIGURE
THIS OUT RIGHT NOW AND THEN I
GOT YOU KNOW I I I WOULD SAY WE
WE UNDERSTAND NATURAL DISASTERS
PRETTY MUCH I THINK WHAT --
MOST OF THE WORLD WOULD LOOK AT
ABOUT IT WHAT I WAS SAYING THERE
SOME SITUATIONS WE PROBABLY
HAVEN'T THOUGHT THROUGH --
A FIRST RESPONDER THOUGH --
AS A DISASTER LET'S SEE
SOMETHING HAPPEN TO NEXT WEEK --
THEY WOULD NOT NEED TO SPEED
CAPITA ALREADY BE OFF SO THEY
DON'T NEED TO WORRY ABOUT THAT
PART OF IT IS THEY GO THROUGH IT --
AND SO THAT'S WHAT WAS I WAS
REFERRING TO AND NOT HAVING TO
TO WORK THROUGH IT I THINK
THERE'S WORK TO BE DONE
INTERNALLY TO MAKE SURE THAT
WE'VE REALLY EXCLUSIVE AND
BECAUSE WE THOUGHT OF ALL THE
SITUATIONS THAT GETTING ANCHOR.
DOES WITH NOTICE AND THOSE
WITHOUT --
AND TO MAKE SURE THAT WE PUT THE
PROPER STEPS IN PLACE SINCE WE
HAVE A COMMITTEE INTERNALLY
THAT'S WORKING ON THAT RIGHT NOW --
AS EVERYTHING HAS BEEN --
BROUGHT TO LIGHT AYE AS YOU
WOULD IMAGINE THERE'S A LOT OF
PEOPLE WITH AMBER EYES AND
ENSURING THAT WE PUT THE RIGHT
STEPS FORWARD SO THAT WE DON'T
HAVE.
THAT THIS TYPE OF SITUATION
HAPPEN AGAIN YOU GOT YOUR MOVING
QUICKLY AND I APPRECIATE THAT
YOU DOING THAT SO TO SPEAK CAPS
ARE LIFTED THERE IS A NEW PLAN
NEXT WEEK AND IT WILL TAKE TIME
FOR THEM.
TO BE ENROLLED IN THAT NEW PLAN
BUT YOU'RE NOT GOING TO STOP
PEOPLE FROM BENEFITING FROM.
THIS STUFF BEFORE YOU GET TO
THAT ABSOLUTE BECAUSE THERE ARE
PEOPLE ON EMERGENCY AND THEY'RE
DOING THEIR JOB AND YOU WILL
WORRY ABOUT BILLING LATER
[inaudible]
CORRECT.
OKAY TWENTY MAKE SURE THAT WAS
CLEAR -- IN
IN THE LIFTING OF RESTRICTIONS
AND THE DEFINITION OF DISASTER.
DO YOU HAVE EIGHTY I ASK ABOUT
THE CRITERIA.
WHO MAKES THE DECISION
ULTIMATELY WHO DEFINES THIS
ORDER OR SAYS YET IT'S ALL BEEN
MATT?
IS THERE SOMEONE IN YOUR IN YOUR
AT CORPORATE --
YOU KNOW HIERARCHY THAT DOES
THAT THERE IS NOT ONE PERSON --
BECAUSE THAT WOULD BE OBVIOUSLY
AND AND A LARGE BOTTLE NECK NAM
IT'S A GROUP OF HAVE COMMITTEE
THAT LOOKS AT ARE THE
REQUIREMENTS BEING MET TOGETHER
AND I WOULD SAY WE STILL NEED TO
DO A BETTER JOB OF DEFINING.
WHAT THOSE ARE REQUIREMENTS ARE
WHICH I SPOKE TO EARLIER FROM A
PROCESS STANDPOINT?BUT IF THERE IS AN ONGOING
INCIDENT AMBER FOR HIMSELF AND
IT LOOKS LIKE IT'S GONNA BE OF
LINK THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN AN
INCIDENT WOULD HAVE TRIGGERED.
I CAN ATTEST THAT COMMITTEES CAN
BE BOTTLENECKS TO YES.
HA AND DIED.
YOU WERE WERE --
YEAH THINKING ABOUT --
THESE FORMAL YOU KNOW POLICIES
AS YOU'RE MAKING THEM HOW --
TRANSPARENT WILL YOU BE.
AND WHAT THOSE YOU KNOW THE
CRITERIA MAY BE WHAT THAT
COMMITTEE OR DECISION MAKING
STRUCTURE IS SO IT'S NOT I WANT
TO DETERMINE WHAT WERE YOU GUYS
ACTUALLY END UP LANDING.
AND AND HOW YOU FLIP THE SWITCH
ON IT IS A DISASTER OR THAT A
DISASTER IS OVER A PRIOR TO AYE
AYE THE GOVERNOR OR SOMEONE ELSE
REFERENCING SOME OFFICIAL
DISASTROUS.
YOU KNOW ANY ANY EMERGENCY IS A
DISASTER FOR PEOPLE THAT ARE AT
YEAH AYE AYE SYRIA GOING YET WE
WOULD NOT BE WAITING FOR A STATE
OF EMERGENCY TO BE CALLED IN AND
THOSE SITUATIONS.
I WOULD TELL YOU WE ARE RELYING
OF FORMER
THAT CURRENTLY WORK WITHIN THE
VERIZON'S ORGANIZATION AS WELL
AS CONSULTANTS ARE ON THAT SIDE
TO HELP US DEFINE --
GOING FORWARD ON THAT SO THAT --
AYE AS YOU SAID EARLIER --
AS WELL LIKE IF IT WERE MORE
EXPERTS ON THE MALL SIDE I WOULD
HATE TO BE ON THE OTHER SIDE
WHERE YOU'RE SITTING TODAY
BECAUSE I WOULDN'T BE ABLE TO
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS.
BOB A APPROPRIATELY AND SO WE'RE
GONNA WILL DEFINITELY UTILIZE
THE RESOURCES THAT WE HAVE AT
OUR DISPOSAL.
AND AND TO THE POINT ABOUT
HAVING HIS FORMAL POLICIES HOW
TRANSPARENT WILL THEY BE SO WE
IS LAWMAKERS OR THE PUBLIC IN
GENERAL TO BE ABLE TO UNDERSTAND
THE DECISION MAKING THAT VERIZON
IS IS USING. TO TO COME TO THESE
CONCLUSIONS WILL YOU BE ABLE TO
SHARE THAT WITH US.
I THINK I AM I DON'T WANT TO AND
I HOW 2% FOR SURE ON THE
MAGNITUDE OF EVERY STEP BUT THE
PROCESS WOULD BE SHARED.
LEARNING FROM THIS ENVIRONMENT --
WITH OUR ACCOUNT REPRESENTATIVES
TO SHARE WITH THEIR SPOCK'S --
POINT A CONTEXT WITHIN --
THE ACCOUNTS TO ENSURE THAT
THEY'RE ABLE TO FOLLOW THE
PROCESS AND THAT WOULD THEN BE A
PUBLIC -- A
PUBLIC A PROCESS THAT WOULD BE
ABLE TO SHARE YEAH BUT HE WAS
STILL WORKING THROUGH THAT TO
MAKE SURE THE STEPS ARE AND AND
PLACE WHICH I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT --
TO ENSURE THAT THAT BEFORE ANY
OF THOSE THINGS HAVE TO BE ONE
PLACE THAT WE WE NOT MOVE
FORWARD ON THE PLAN WE HAVE
SPEED CAPS REMOVED AND WE ALLOW
PEOPLE TO GET SERVICE --
APPROPRIATELY SELF THEY NEED TO
IN THE NEXT UP THEY'RE ABLE TO
GET IT DONE AT THE SPEED
RESTRICTIONS ON THE DATA USED BY
FIRST RESPONDERS AND IN THIS.
INSTANCE THE SANTA CLARA COUNTY
FIRED AGENCY --
IS ONE OF THE FACT THAT THEY HAD --
I CAP --
KIND OF A FALSE CAP THEY'RE
ALLOWED TO GO OVER THE CAP AND
PURCHASE MORE DATA BUT I IF IT
WAS YOUR KID --
JUST WATCHING VIDEOS ON THEIR
PHONE BUT FOR FIRST RESPONDERS.
NOT APPROPRIATE AND AND SO THAT
WAS JUST A MATTER OF HITTING
THEIR CAP AND THEREFORE HAVING A
SPEED RESTRICTION PUT IN PLACE
AND SO THANK YOU FOR TAKING IT
OFF.
IT IS CONFLATED ARE OFTEN THIS
WEEK WITH --
THE ISSUE OF NET NEUTRALITY
WHICH THE LEGISLATURE IS ALSO
DETERMINING AND AND IN IN IS A
BIT OF A DIFFERENT ISSUE WHEREAS
A SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE.
AT YOU YOU MIGHT DESCRIBE THIS
DIFFERENTLY BUT MORE OF THAT
TOLL TAKERS IF YOU WILL ON THE
INFORMATION SUPERHIGHWAY PAIN --
CHARGING MORE FOR CONTENT
PROVIDERS TO BE ON THOSE ROADS --
SO TO SPEAK UP IN IN IN THE
INTERNET --
TO THROUGH YOUR SERVICE AND
DELIVERY TO THE CUSTOMER VERSUS
JUST HITTING AT A DATA CAP --
DON'T SPEAK AT ALL ABOUT THAT
DIFFERENCE TO CLARIFY THAT
BECAUSE IT HAS COME UP AYE IN
THE CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
IN AND PEOPLE ARE CURIOUS ABOUT
THAT YEAH SURE AND I AND I I
KNOW THAT MY COLLEAGUE HIDE YOU
PERSONALLY ADDRESS THIS AT THE
COMMITTEE HEARING.
YESTERDAY AND THE DAY BEFORE BUT
THIS ISSUE IS NOT ABOUT --
NET NEUTRALITY IS --
ONE ASPECT OF IT.
ADDRESSES THE ISSUE OF CONTENT
DISCRIMINATION RIGHT THE
HYPOTHETICAL SITUATION WHERE I
INTERNET SERVICE PROVIDER WOULD.
SPEED ACCESS TO YOU KNOW HOW YOU
KNOW SO CALLED FAVORED.
CONTENT ON THE INTERNET ARE
FAVORED WEBSITES AND SLOW DOWN
ACCESS TO DISFAVORED --
CONTENT --
WE'VE MADE IT CLEAR IN OUR
BROADBAND COMMITMENT WE DO NOT
DO THAT.
THE INDUSTRY HAS MADE CLEAR IT
DOES NOT DO THAT --
THIS SITUATION IS NOT THAT THIS
WAS A SITUATION WHERE A CUSTOMER --
REACHED AND ITS PRE PRESCRIBED
LIMIT OF ITS CONTRACTUALLY
AGREED TO DATA PLAN AND AS A
RESULT THE SPEEDS WERE REDUCED.
WE TO PROCESS THEM YEAH A MORE
INFORMAL PROCESS IN PLACE WHERE
THOSE WOULD BE LIFTED AND AN
ERROR WAS MADE IT WAS
OPERATIONAL AND WE'VE.
ADDRESSED HERE SO.
THESE ARE TWO COMPLETELY
SEPARATE HA SITUATIONS TOTALLY
UNRELATED TO THE ISSUE OF NET
NEUTRALITY.
AND I THINK YOU HURT FOR MAKING
THAT NO I DIDN'T ASK YOU YOU
KNOW WITH THIS SWEEPING REFORM
OF LIFTING SPEED RESTRICTIONS
FOR FIRST RESPONDERS IN A NEW
PLAN NEXT WEEK.
HOW MUCH HAVE YOU COORDINATED
WITH YOUR PEER --
CORPORATIONS THAT PROVIDE THE
SERVICES AS WELL I NOW I GUESS
YOU CAN'T --
YOU KNOW YOU'RE NOT AT A CARTEL
WHERE YOU CAN SET.
RATES --
TOGETHER --
LIKE SETTING THE PRICE OF OIL SO
HAVE YOU BEEN ABLE TO TALK TO
THEM ABOUT THIS OR SYSTEM THAT
YOU'RE DOING ON YOUR OWN THAT
YOU CAN'T ACTUALLY DO
COORDINATION ON PRICE SETTING.
SO NO NO --
WHEAT WHEAT DEFTLY TAKE CARE OF
INTERNALLY --
WHAT WE HAVE UNDER OUR
JURISDICTION --
AND UNDER OUR CONTROL I WOULD
SAY THOUGH IT DOES --
AND BIG NEED FOR INTER OPERATE
SURE THAT YOU KNOW AS A FIRST
RESPONDER THAT YOU CAN SPEAK
ACROSS MULTIPLE NETWORKS --
AND WE ARE WORKING WITH OUR
COMPETITORS ARE TRYING TO HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS --
TO ENSURE THAT THE AYE FIRST
RESPONDERS TAKEN CARE OF
REGARDLESS OF THE NETWORK THERE
ON AT INTEROPERABLE HE'S
EXTRAORDINARILY IMPORTANT SO
THANKS FOR MAKING THAT NOTE WE
DID INVITE OTHER SERVICE
PROVIDERS TO COME UP IN AND TALK
ABOUT IT FROM AN INDUSTRY
PERSPECTIVE AND AND I UNDERSTAND
THAT THEY DECLINED --
THAT IT WOULD BE INTERESTING TO
SEE IF THESE CHANGES ARE
SWEEPING ACROSS THE SECTOR THAT
FIRST RESPONDERS ABLE TO BENEFIT
NO MATTER.
WHAT THEIR PLAN IS I AND WHO
THEIR SERVICE PROVIDER IS --
SO I WILL AT THIS POINT IF THERE
ARE NO OTHER QUESTIONS FROM THE
DAY AS SAY THANK YOU --
TO REPRESENT US FROM VERIZON AND
I'M VERY GRATEFUL THAT YOU
PARTICIPATED --
AND DOT DID YOU DO YOU HAVE A
COMMENT YET MYSTERIES MISTER I
JUST HAVE A QUICK QUESTION AS
YOU MOVE FORWARD WITH THE
CHANGES AND BETTER HAVE ACCESS --
WILL YOU BE ABLE TO WORK WITH
THE LOCAL IMAGE AGENCY WHERE THE
FIREFIGHTERS POLICE OFFICERS
MAYBE HAVE THEM AT THE TABLE AS
WELL. TO SEE MOVING FORWARD ON
THE BEST FIT FROM THEIR
PERSPECTIVE AS WELL I KNOW YOU
GUYS HAVE YOUR YOUR SPECIALISTS
AND EARN YOUR DEPARTMENT.
BUT I THINK WOULD BE GOOD TO
HAVE THE FIREFIGHTERS THE POLICE
OFFICER WHERE THAT MAY BE.
AT THE TABLE AS WELL TO TALK
ABOUT MAYBE OTHER INSTANCES
THERE ARE OTHER THINGS THAT MAY
OCCUR THAT MAKE SURE THAT WE
HAVE THE BEST PLAN.
MOVING FORT SO THAT'S ODD MATURE
THROUGHOUT THE TABLES WERE
ABSOLUTELY.
RIGHT SO WE WILL WE WILL HAVE
PUBLIC COMMENT BEFORE CLOSING
STATEMENTS AND I SO I THINK YOU
ARE THE THREE OF YOU FROM HER
EYES AND FOR BEING HERE TODAY I
REALLY APPRECIATE THE CHAIRS
MEMBERS COMMITTEE THANK.
AND AND SO I THINK THERE MAY
NEED THE MICROPHONE --
OVER BY WHERE THOSE CAMERAS ARE.
IF IF ANYONE WOULD LIKE TO
PARTICIPATE IN PUBLIC COMMENT --
THAT YOU ARE ABLE TO DO SO NOW
[inaudible]
ALRIGHT SO THAT WILL BE THE LAST
CALL FOR PUBLIC COMMENT MEMBERS
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE ANY CLOSING
STATEMENTS.
ALRIGHT SO I I'LL ON ASK --
MY COLLEAGUE AND CO CHAIR MISLI
KNOWN TO MAKERS CAME FOR IDEA
RIGHT THANK YOU I JUST WANT TO
THANK EVERYONE WHO'S
PARTICIPATED I THINK AND THERE'S
A FEW TAKEAWAYS ONE THAT IT'S AN
ISSUE THAT THIS AD THAT MATTERS
TO THE STATE LEGISLATURE.
AND PUBLIC SAFETY IS SOMETHING
THAT WE THINK ABOUT PARTICULARLY
IN LIGHT OF THE NUMBER OF
NATURAL DISASTERS THAT ARE
HAPPENING.
AND TWO THAT THERE IS AN
INTERESTING.
AND OUTSIDE OF THIS PARTICULAR
HEARING TO UNDERSTAND WHAT WE
CAN DO HOW WE REPLICATE BEST
PRACTICES AND ENSURE THAT THIS
IS -- THESE
INCIDENTS DON'T TRANSLATE INTO
ANY PATTERNS ARE TENS UM AND
THREE DATA IT IS CLEAR THAT --
YOU KNOW ONE OF OUR BIGGER
TELECOMMUNICATIONS I ENTITIES
AND I IN OUR COUNTRY IS MOVING
FORWARD WITH A DIFFERENT PLAN
AND THAT WE WOULD LIKE. TO SEE
AND HEAR HOW OTHERS ALSO
RESPONDED IF THIS IS SOMETHING
AND THAT IS TAKEN INTO
CONSIDERATION.
I KNOW THAT --
THE THOMAS FIRE I SPENT FORTY
DAYS --
DEALING WITH THAT PARTICULAR
NATURAL DISASTER AND THERE WERE
SO MANY MISTAKES I MADE ERRORS --
I HAD THAT HAPPENED --
IT'S HARD TO PREVENT AND PREDICT
ALL OF THEM.
AND WE DO EVERYTHING WE CAN TO
ENSURE THAT THEY DON'T HAPPEN
AGAIN -- AND
THAT THEY ARE.
PIECES OF THE I'M A BIGGER
CONVERSATION AND THAT --
WILL NOT IMPACT THE SAFETY OF
ANY INDIVIDUALS --
SO I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT TO
IDENTIFY WHAT THOSE ARE I FEEL
LIKE OUR COMMITTEE HAS DONE THAT
TODAY.
ON WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO IDENTIFY
THAT BUT ALSO WHAT THE SOLUTION
WILL BE MOVING FORWARD I WANT TO
THANK EVERYBODY INVOLVED
ESPECIALLY ALL OF OUR COLLEAGUES
AND IT COULD HAVE BEEN ON THEIR
WEIGHT BACK TO THEIR DISTRICT TO
SERVE YOUR CONSTITUENTS THAT
HAVE STAYED HERE --
TO BE PART OF THIS CONVERSATION
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU MADAM COCHAIR --
WANT TO SAY THANK YOU EVERYONE
WHO PARTICIPATED TODAY --
THAT REPRESENTS FROM VERIZON
ALSO CHIEF OUT AND THIS.
WAS NOT A FIRE DRILL WE HAD OF
THE MOST DESTRUCTIVE FIRES IN
THE STATE'S HISTORY JUST LAST
YEAR.
SO I THINK WE ALL WERE I
SURPRISED THAT SUCH AN INCIDENT
CAN OCCUR AGAIN I'M GRATEFUL
THAT DIED THAT RISING RECOGNIZES.
THAT THEY NEED TO CHANGE THE WAY
THAT THEY DO THEIR BUSINESS AND
I AND I AM GRATEFUL AGAIN FOR
CHIEF BOWDEN'S LEADERSHIP TO
MAKE SURE THAT HIS STORY.
IS TOLD THANK YOU ALL FOR
PARTICIPATING [inaudible]
VETERANS OVER [inaudible]
MOVING [inaudible]
DON DOT